GONNA GET STARTED NOW WE HAVE
MEMBER MEMBERS TRICKLING IN.
AS WE DO THAT WE CAN GET THIS --
COMMITTEE STARTED WERE WELCOME
TO THE COMMITTEE.
ON ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS --
THIS IS OUR OVERSIGHT HEARING OF
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION ON THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
FORMERLY IT'S WAS RECENTLY
RENAMED AS FORMALLY KNOWN AS THE
OFFICE OF REPAIR ADVOCATES --
FOR THOSE THAT WERE MORE
FAMILIAR WITH THAT ORGANIZATION
TO SAME ONCE WITH A DIFFERENT
NAME -- WE
WILL BEGIN TODAY WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION --
WE'RE GONNA BE HEARING FROM
MICHAEL PICKER.
AN ALLIS STUBBINS --
TODAY REPRESENTING THEM
[inaudible]
BOB.
CAN REGISTER SOME OVERSIGHT
COMMENT I MEAN JUST SOME A
PRELIMINARY COMMENTS LIKE MAKE
FEW.
OF REGARDING THIS PAST YEAR.
ANOTHER EXTREMELY ACTIVE YEAR --
ESPECIALLY ON THE ISSUE RELATED
TO THE CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES --
NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH THE
CAMPFIRE IN PARADISE --
JUST.
COMPLETELY OBLITERATED THE TOWN
AND FOURTEEN THOUSAND RESIDENCES
THIS IS PROBABLY --
THE THE THE ISSUE THAT HAS.
OF ALL THE FIRES AND ALL OF A
MORE DEVASTATING ALL OF THEM
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION BUT THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR.
THAT THE YOU KNOW IGNITED --
BY --
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE
[inaudible]
HAS AS HAS A BEEN BEEN A ISSUE
THAT HAS --
REALLY BECAUSE YOU KNOW FOR HIS
RETURN THE LEGISLATURE TO TO
THIS THIS ISSUE.
AND HAS CAUSED A LOT OF ACTIVITY
IN THE MARKETS AND THAT HAS LED
TO THESE DOWNGRADE TO THE
UTILITIES NOW POSING A PROBLEM.
FOR OUR STATE OUR RATE PAYERS
AND JUST THE WHOLE.
THE ISSUE OF LIABILITY --
BRING IN THIS DEBATE FORWARD --
IT'S IT'S A AT TIMES CAN REQUIRE.
I AM AND MY OPINION LEGISLATIVE
ACTION AND FOUR WERE GOING
THROUGH THAT BUT I ALSO
[inaudible]
ON A HERE FROM THE P. YOU SEE IN
TERMS OF THE PERSPECTIVES ON
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENED
RECENTLY.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
CONVENED A CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
AND ADOPTED SB NINE A ONE THAT
REQUIRED A NUMBER OF ACTIONS BY
THE CPUC UTILITIES TO REDUCE.
ARE THE WILD FIRE RISK IN A JUST
HOW COST RECOVER.
CURRY IN DAMAGES ARE HANDLED AND
OF COURSE THAT IS ALSO.
AT THE ADDITIONAL PROCESS.
AS I MENTIONED P. GINNY FIRED
FOR TO FILE FOR CHAPTER ELEVEN
REORGANIZATION BANKRUPTCY.
WHAT TO ADDRESS THESE --
CLAIMS.
A SEVEN FROM --
FIRES IGNITED BY THEIR EQUIPMENT
INCLUDING THOSE THAT MAY RESULT
IN THE CAMP FIRE.
JUST LAST WEEK OR COMMITTEE HELD
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
P. GINNY BANKRUPTCY CASE --
JUST -- TO
GET THE PUBLIC AND MEMBERS AT A
MORE FAMILIAR WITH --
THE BANKRUPTCY PROCESS AND WHAT
IT ENTAILS AND HOW IT AFFECTS
[inaudible]
OUR UTILITIES.
ALL OF THE THIS COMING IN ON ON
THE HEELS OF YEARS OF REFORM
EFFORTS OF THE OF THE P. UC CPUC
AS WELL AS OF THE CONTINUED
ISSUES STEMMING FROM THE MAJOR
LEGALLY SO CANYON.
I AND DECISIONS AND ACTIONS TO
THE COMMISSION TO NUCLEAR PLANTS
IN THE STATE AND OF COURSE THE
DEVASTATION CAUSED BY THE BRUNO
POP HI PLAN EXPLOSION.
CPUC IS AN AGENCY THAT IS ALSO
HAVING TO ADJUST TO THE TO THE
CHANGE IN ENERGY LANDSCAPE.
AND IT CONTINUES ITS OVERSIGHT
AND REGULATION OF TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE.
WHICH IS ALSO.
WHAT'S ALSO SEEN NUMEROUS OF
LEGISLATIVE.
AMENDMENTS TO THAT [inaudible]
REGULATORY PROCESS.
AND ALSO --
RATE REGULATE WATER UTILITIES
AND TRANSPORTATION FOR HIRE.
ARE ALL ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR THE PC THAT
WHERE THEY CONTINUE.
TO PROVIDE --
PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND AND QUIRK
AND REFORMS AND CHANGES TO HOW.
THE PC OPERATES.
TODAY WE WILL HEAR --
THE ANNUAL REPORT --
FROM THE CPUC WHICH HAD A CHANCE
TO REVIEW AND EVERY YEAR KEEPS
GETTING A LITTLE BIT FATTER.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION BUT ALSO HIGHLIGHTS
ALL THE WORK THE CPUC HAS DONE.
IN RESPONSE TO NOT ONLY THESE --
CHECK A CREASE CHALLENGES IN OUR
COMMUNITY BUT ALSO TO NEW
LEGISLATION.
THAT IS NOT ONLY PROVIDED PC
WITH NEW DIRECTION AND NEW
REGULATORY --
RULES -- BUT
ALSO --
REQUIRE IN OF THE PC
[inaudible]
A TWO OUR TAKE ON NEW NEW
CHALLENGES THAT THEY HAVEN'T HAD
TO DO BEFORE --
TODAY WE WILL ALSO HEAR OF THE
ANNUAL REPORT.
INCLUDED IN THE C. P. UC'S
REPORTERS HOT HOT.
AS TO HOW TO DRESS IN SAFETY.
AFFORDABILITY AND RELIABILITY.
AS WELL AS THE STATUS OF IMPLANT
AND PLANTING THE MANY BILLS OVER
THE YEARS.
RELATED TO REFORM IN THE AGENCY
IMPROVING SAFETY IMPLEMENTED
CLEAN AND CLEAN ENERGY POLICY
EXPANDING BROADBAND SERVICE AND
MANY OTHERS.
THAT'S OF COURSE IN ADDITION TO
THE NUMEROUS PERSONNEL CHANGES
THE AGENCY HAS ALREADY.
UNDERGONE INCLUDING A NEW
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
THE ROOT RECENT APPOINTMENT OF A
NW COMMISSIONER HIGHER IN
NEARLY A QUARTER.
OF ITS STAFF NEW STAFF THERE ON
BOARD TO DIRECT THE AGENCY'S
ACTIVITIES.
AND SEVERAL OTHER MANAGEMENT
CHANGES WITHIN THE AGENCY.
SO -- WELL
NOT FOR THEIR DO I LIKE.
TO WELCOME THE CQC WITNESSES
TODAY.
CLOTHING --
MICHAEL PICKER.
THE PRESIDENT THE CPU CIALIS
DEVON SIX SECOND OF DIRECTOR --
FROM OF THE CPUC AND AFTER WE
HEAR FROM SI PC WILL HEAR FROM
THE AND ANY ENTITY FORMALLY
NOTICES AS KNOWN AS THE OFFICE
OF REPAIR ADVOCATES WELCOME AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
HI MICHAEL BAKER AND JOIN BUYER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR ALICE
STEBBINS LEE PALMER FROM OUR
SAFETY IN ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
STEPPING IN --
FOR FOR LISA BETTER MALASHENKO
WHOSE WAY ON FAMILY BUSINESS AND
EDWARD RANDOLPH WHO IS OUR
ENERGY DIVISION DIRECTOR.
SO I FEEL LIKE I I'M REALLY
OBLIGATED TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
FROM OUR ANNUAL REPORT BECAUSE
IT'S WHAT WHAT YOU ACTUALLY A
STATUTE OF DIRECTED US TO
PROVIDE TO YOU SO I'LL TAKE A
FEW MINUTES AND THEN HOPEFULLY
WILL HAVE LOTS OF TIME FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS.
LAKE THAT'S ALWAYS MORE
INSTRUCTIVE FOR FOR LEGISLATORS.
SO.
PIECE OF GOOD NEWS --
AN UPDATE ON CLEAN ENERGY IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC.
SUPPLIED 33% OF ITS CUSTOMERS
WITH FILE ELECTRICITY FROM
RENEWABLE SOURCES.
IN TWENTY TWENTY THEY EXPECT TO
BE AT ABOUT 56% OF THEIR
ELECTRICITY COMING FROM THOSE
CLEAN ENERGY SOURCES.
A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WAS A 28%
BY TWENTY TWENTY THEY EXPECT TO
BE AT 40%.
SENIOR GAS ELECTRIC IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WAS AT 43% AND
AND TWENTY TWENTY EXPECTS TO BE
A FORTY FIVE POINT 2%.
THIS IS ALL FAR IN ADVANCE OF
THE EARLIER LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION THAT THEY WOULD BE AT
33% BY --
TWENTY TWENTY THE THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO CONTRACT THE PRICES
FELL NINE POINT FOR PER YEAR
BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AVERAGE PRICE
ACROSS THE PORTFOLIO IN
CALIFORNIA WAS FOUR POINT SEVEN
CENTS PER KILOWATT HOUR.
SOME UNVERIFIED REPORTS THERE
WE'VE HEARD IN THE SOUTHWEST OF
TO CENTS PER KILOWATT HOUR
DESERT SOLAR IN FOR SENT --
ON A PER KILOWATT HOUR SOLAR
PLUS BATTERY KEEP GETTING
REPEATED SO THIS THE LEGISLATURE
THE CITY CALIFORNIA STRATEGY.
OF FORCING THE PROCUREMENT OF
OUR ENERGY OUR ELECTRICAL ENERGY
FROM THESE CLEAN SOURCES.
HAS PROVEN TO BE A GOOD BATH
BOTH IN TERMS OF SUCCESS IN
ACTUALLY BUILDING THE PROJECTS
AND AND CONNECTING THEM AND
PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH RELIABLE
ELECTRICITY.
BUT ALSO IN TERMS OF BRINGING
THE PRICE DOWN BY CREATING A
LARGER MARKET AND MORE
COMPETITION --
SO THAT'S IN OR IN OUR OCTOBER
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ANNUAL
REPORT ON THE RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD.
I'LL JUST MENTION A FEW OTHER
THINGS --
MAJOR FOCUS INTERNALLY WE HAVE A
NEW EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WHO HAS
UNDERTAKEN A WHOLE SERIES OF
INTERNAL RESTRUCTURING.
WE HAVE MUCH STRONGER BUSINESS
SYSTEMS ALREADY AS A RESULT OF
OUR EFFORTS --
WERE BEGINNING TO WORK WITH CAL
LIKE TEA AND OUR NEW I. T.
DIRECTOR TO MOVE INTO THE TO THE
EARLY TWENTIETH CENTURY SOME DAY
WE HOPE TO CATCH UP TO
TECHNOLOGIES EXIST TODAY.
WE HAVE NEW INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL AUDITORS WE HAD A
RETIREMENT AND WE ACTUALLY
REPLACED ONE WE WANT TO GET
STRONGER IN TERMS OF OUR ABILITY
TO ACTUALLY DO THAT BUT WE'RE
TRACKING BETTER CANDIDATES NOW
THAN WE DID SEVERAL YEARS AGO%
WHEN WE ACTUALLY FIRST MADE THE
EFFORT TO BUILD.
UP THOSE PROGRAMS.
PROGRESS IN RESOLVING OUR
PROCEEDINGS WITHIN TIME LINES.
SO TWO HUNDRED NINE PROCEEDINGS
LAST YEAR WERE RESOLVED IN A
TIMELY FASHION. THIRTY THREE
WERE RESOLVED WITH EXTENSION
ANYWHERE FROM TWO WEEKS TO SIX
MONTHS MOST OF THOSE WERE
ACTUALLY TO ACCOMMODATE SETTLING
PARTIES.
AS PEOPLE GOT CLOSE TO THE
DEADLINES THEY ACTUALLY STARTED
TO MEET TO DEVELOP SETTLEMENTS.
SO THEN WE HAVE TO REVIEW THE
SETTLEMENTS TO WITH CALIFORNIA
LAW AND THAT DURING THE RATE
PAYERS INTEREST.
SO NATURALLY TENSE TAKE A BIT
LONGER. ZERO OF THE THE
PROCEEDINGS THAT WE THAT WE
EXPECTED TO COMPLETE LAST YEAR
RESERVE LATE WE HAVE ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX
PROCEEDINGS UNDER WAY.
OF THAT ARE WITHIN TIME LINES.
I'LL SAY THAT THERE'S ONE SET OF
EXCEPTIONS WHICH IS THE THE
GENERAL RATE CASES PARTICULARLY
FOR THE LARGE ENERGY UTILITIES.
THERE BECAUSE OF THE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND THE CHALLENGES
PARTICULARLY OF THE THE SAFETY
RATE MAKING SECTIONS THAT THERE
WERE ALL LEARNING HOW TO IMPROVE.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY PROPOSALS THAT
HAVE COME FORWARD FROM FROM SOME
OF THE PARTIES INCLUDING THE THE
UTILITIES AND THE RIGHT PAIR
ADVOCATE.
THAT WE CONSIDER A FOUR YEAR --
CYCLE FOR GENERATE CASES RATHER
THAN THREE WE HAVE NOT MADE THAT
DECISION YET BUT I THINK THAT
THERE'S A WIDESPREAD
UNDERSTANDING THE COMPLEXITY.
OF THE THINGS THAT WERE ASKING
THE UTILITIES TO PURCHASE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
ARE MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
TRY TO DO THAT WITHIN THE THREE
YEAR CYCLE AND IT THAT BECOMES
SOMEWHAT PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE WE
FIND THAT PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY.
WELL INTO THEIR NEXT CYCLE
HAVING RESOLVED WHAT THE
EXPENDITURE PLANS ARE GOING TO
BE AND WHAT THE WAY WE'RE GOING
TO CARVE IT UP BETWEEN DIFFERENT
CLASSES OF CUSTOMERS.
YOU'RE SAYING YOU HAVEN'T
DECIDED IF YOU'RE GONNA GO TO
FOUR YEARS THERE'S NOT COMPLETE
AGREEMENT WE SHOULD DO THAT I'M
JUST SAYING THAT THERE'S SOME
THERE'S SOME MOMENTUM AMONG SOME
PARTIES THAT DIRECTION WE'RE
STILL STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT
IF THERE'S WAYS THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY TRY TO DO WITHIN.
THE THREE YEAR CYCLE RATHER THAN
JUST LETTING IT DRAG ON CURRENT.
OF THE UTILITIES --
YOU'RE ON THE ON THE SECOND YEAR
OF THE RATE.
ADJUSTMENTS OF ONLY ONLY ON ONE
ONLY ON ONE BUT I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW WHERE YOU ARE ON ON ON
THOSE RIGHT NOW AS FAR AS WE
JUST STARTED IN.
WE TEND TO WE DON'T TEND TO DO
THEM ALL AT ONCE SO WE CYCLE
THEM SO THERE WERE THERE WERE
ONLY PURSUING ONE OF THE MAJORS
ENTITY GIVE TIME WE KICK IT OFF.
AND THEN IT WOULD THEN THE
OVERLAP SOME BUT IT ALLOWS US TO
DO THAT I WAS ACTUALLY LOOKING
FOR THAT INFORMATION IN THE
REPORT BECAUSE I DON'T FIND IT
DO YOU HAVE THAT INFORMATION AS
FAR AS WHAT IS THE THE CURRENT
TIMELINE ON THOSE RATE CASES
WHERE YOU ARE.
I CAN WHICH MEANS ARE YOU READY
WE NOW WHERE ARE YOU YEAH I I
CAN SPEAK TO THE BIG THREE
ELECTRIC AND NATURAL GAS UTILITY
TO CAN'T SPEAK --
TO OTHER RATE CASES BUT FOR ON
P. JEANNIE THERE AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF A GENERAL RATE CASE
CYCLE THEY FILED THEIR GENERATE
CASE PLAN IN DECEMBER --
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
EDISON WE ARE ON SUBSTANTIALLY
LATE WITH FINISHING THEIR
CURRENT RATE CASE CYCLE ON BATCH
YOU KNOW THE BEGINNING OF THE
ACTUAL CYCLE WAS --
WHERE WE 200-019-2000 --
EIGHT AND SO THAT'S PROBABLY
SEVERAL MONTHS AWAY FROM JANUARY
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN YES.
YEAH OKAY --
AND THEN --
WERE ALSO IN THE REVIEW PROCESS
OF SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC.
I SLASH --
SO CAL GASES GENERATE CASE ON IN
THEIR RATE CASE --
CYCLE --
WOULD HAVE STARTED ON JANUARY OF
THIS YEAR.
OKAY ALSO IT WOULD HAVE STARTED
BUT HASN'T STARTED HAVING
STARTED SO THERE ON THAT WHAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CONCLUDED WE
SHOULD MADE A FINAL DECISION BY
THAT TIME SO AND YOUR ARE YOU
AWARE OF A BILL THAT WAS
INTRODUCED TO ADDRESS THE TIMING
OF THESE RAPE CASES WITH.
SMALLER UTILITIES UP.
RELATED [inaudible]
TO PHONE SERVICE I'M I'M NOT
YEAH OKAY ON THE DIED
UNFORTUNATE DON'T TRACK THE THE
SMALL TELCO GENERATE CASES.
AND SOWITH ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES OF POINT OUT THAT
WHAT EVERYBODY IS WRESTLING WITH
INCLUDING THE UTILITIES IS THE
IMPACT OF THE NEW FEDERAL TAX
CODES AND HOW TO ACTUALLY TRACK
THAT AND WHAT THE APPROPRIATE
WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT IS --
ON THAT BE HAPPY TO SEND YOU
SOME OF THE MATERIALS FROM THAT
PROCEEDING IT'S NOT MINE SO.
I'M GOING TO SPEAK TO THAT WHAT
IN OTHER COMMISSIONERS DOING.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
BEEN.
DRESSING WITH IS THE AMOUNT OF
OVERLAP BETWEEN THINGS THAT WE
DO AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND
SO USED TO BE THERE WE WERE JUST
RAY MAKING AGENCY FOR UTILITIES
AND WE SORT OF STOOD OFF TO THE
SIDE.
BUT I'LL JUST POINT TO THE
AMOUNT OF I HAVE MONEY THAT
PASSES THROUGH THE CPUC --
FOR ENTERED THAT LITHIUM BATTERY
STORAGE OR FOR ROOFTOP SOLAR
WE'RE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENS TO THOSE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT ARE FUNDED BY RATE PAYERS
AT THE END OF LIFE TO THE JUST
OVERSEAS WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
BECOME A HAZARD TO COMMUNITIES
THERE.
SO TO WE DON'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT
RECYCLING MARKET SOON IN SOME
RESPECTS WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
TOXIC EFFECTS OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES THAT WE DON'T HAVE --
BIOCHEMISTS WE DON'T HAVE --
A PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS.
SO IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO TO
THINK ABOUT THESE THINGS
COHERENTLY IN TO DO A GOOD JOB
WE FORM ALLIANCES WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES.
SO FOR EXAMPLE WE USE FOR JUST
SIGNED A NEW I'M MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH CAL RECYCLES
AND DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL AND RECYCLING
IN END OF LIFE MANAGEMENT OF
BATTERY STORAGE AND SOLAR.
PHOTOVOLTAIC.
PANELS.
WE JUST DON'T WANT TO SEE THEM
LET LITTERING THE CALIFORNIA
LANDSCAPE WERE POTENTIALLY NOT
BEING REUSED OF POSSIBLE --
AND IT'S AN EXAMPLE OF THE WAY
THAT OUR WORLD HAS CHANGED.
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THE
EXPERTISE THE SKILLS OR THE
PERSONALITY TERMINALLY?
ANOTHER GOOD EXAMPLE WOULD BE
OUR SEVERAL YEARS OF WORK WITH
CAL FIRE TO DEVELOP NEW FUELS
MAP. FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ON THE OUR FIRE MAPS THERE THEN --
COUPLE TO NEW STANDARD AND
MANAGE WE NOW HAVE THE TOUGHEST
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT STANDARDS
IN THE COUNTRY.
AND AGAIN WE DON'T HAVE
FORESTERS WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE
WHO WHO REALLY KNOW HOW FIRES
BEHAVE WHERE THE FUELS ARE SO WE
HAD TO ROOM WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH CAL FIRE TO DO THAT.
WITH THEIR FIRE SCIENTISTS IN
WITH THEIR FIRE ENGINEERS MANY
OF WHOM WORKED SEASONALLY ON THE
FIRE LINES AND SO THE TO THE
EVEN THE PACE OF WHAT OF THESE
RELATIONSHIPS CAN BE A CHALLENGE.
WE WORK WITH BOTH CAL FIRE AND
YES TO DEVELOP NEW BETTER
PATTERNS FOR THE D. ENERGY
STATION PROGRAMS THAT --
YOU'VE TACITUS WITHIN --
SB NINE A ONE WE'VE ACTUALLY
BEEN USING A CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
OUR PERFORM SOME OF THE LAND USE
PERMITTING THAT WE DO AROUND
TRANSMISSION --
AND THEN WE HAVE A VERY A LONG
STANDING RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND THE
CALIFORNIA.
INDEPENDENT SYSTEM OPERATOR ON
ELECTRICITY.
RELIABILITY GAS RELIABILITY WE
IS WHERE WE START TO REALLY DIG
IN TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND GAS MARKETS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH THE THE
LIMITATIONS ARE PUSHED PLACED ON
THE LEASE --
CANYON GAS STORAGE FACILITY.
SO NEW POLICY INITIATIVES
BUILDING THE CARBONIZATION
PURSUANT TO SB THREE FIFTY AND
SB --
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SENATOR
STERN'S BILL --
THOUGH WE HAVE A IT'S TO
PROCEEDINGS UNDER WAY ON DISK
AND WE ARE WE ARE DIGGING IN
HARD ON THE NEW --
S. CHIP BOB PROGRAMS --
FOR BECOME A BATTERY STORAGE.
I SPENT SEVERAL YEARS TRACKING
THE PROCESS TO ACTUALLY CLOSE
DIABLO CANYON --
AND WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT THE
D. COMMISSION ACCOUNTS.
AND THEN FOR EXAMPLE THE
TRANSMISSION ELECTRIFICATION WE
HAVE FOURTEEN DIFFERENT PILOT
PROGRAMS OUT ON THE STREETS.
I WANT TO POINT TO A AN AREA OF
ENORMOUS SUCCESS OR UTILITY
DIVERSITY CONTRACTING PROGRAM.
MOST PEOPLE ARE PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT THE FOLKS IN
THE AUDIENCE WHO MAY NOT KNOW
IT'S A PROCESS VOLUNTARY PROCESS
THAT GOES BACK TO TWO IS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GWEN MOORE.
WHO CALLED ON THE UTILITIES T.
K. ACTUALLY AVOID LEAKAGE
LEAKING THEIR CONTRACT AHLERS
SAID OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA?
AND SO INSTEAD.
WE'VE ASKED THEM TO TAKE THE
EXTRA EFFORT TO FIND CONTRACTORS
AND SUBCONTRACTORS YOU REPRESENT
PARSONS OF CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
ECONOMY THAT WOULDN'T OTHERWISE
BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH A VERY
LARGE CORPORATION.
SO DISABLED VATS --
WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES ON IN
NATIVE AMERICAN OF THIS IN THE
IN THE DESERT.
ALL HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING IN
THE UTILITY'S PARTICULARLY THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND THE GAS
UTILITIES HAVE DONE A FAIRLY
GOOD JOB AT THIS POINT.
WE CAN MEASURE TEN POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS.
BILLION WITH A B. THEY GO TO
PARTS OF THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
WOULD THAT WOULD THAT WE
WOULDN'T OTHERWISE HAVE SEEN
INVESTMENT THIS IS IMPORTANT
IT'S DIFFERENT THAN THE
EMPLOYMENT.
THAT THAT THAT ENERGY PROVIDERS
DO FOR THEIR STAFF OF PEOPLE WHO
CONTRACT WITH THEM TO TO BUILD
POWER PLANTS.
THIS ISN'T JUST JOBS ACTUALLY
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF THESE
COMMUNITIES TO FURTHER --
RETAIN WEALTH AT THE HIGHER
PEOPLE WITHIN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND TO TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
REST OF THE ECONOMY SO I THINK
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM WE
PAY A LOT OF ATTENTION TO IT.
THIS YEAR WE'RE ACTUALLY GONNA
HAVE ARE ON BY A CALL WE CALL
THE EXECUTIVES OF THE COMPANY TO
SIT BEFORE THE COMMISSION AND TO
EXPLAIN TO US WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING.
HOW THERE AND ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT CHALLENGES THAT THEY'RE
FACING?
IN FRESNO BECAUSE AS WE BEGIN TO
LOOK AT IT WE START TO SEE THAT
THERE PORTIONS OF THE STATE WHO
HAVE NOT HAD AS MUCH SUCCESS
PARTICIPATING IN THESE PROGRAMS
AS OTHERS.
WE ALSO NOTE.
THAT AS THERE ARE MANY --
QUESTIONS OF THE UTILITY
BUSINESS THEIR DEPARTING AS A
RESULT OF LEGISLATIVE --
CHANGES AND ROOFTOP SOLAR FOR
EXAMPLE THEY'RE NOT
PARTICIPATING IN THESE PROGRAMS
EVEN THOUGH THE PROGRAM IS
GROWING.
IT'S MORE THE EXISTING --
YOU IN RIDING THE SUCCESS OF
THIS PROGRAM WE'RE STRUGGLING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO BRING THESE
OTHER PARTIES INTO IT I KNOW
THAT SENATOR BRADFORD HAS BEEN
LOOKING AT THIS ISSUE AS WELL IN
THIS IS PROPOSING LEGISLATION.
SO FOR A VOLUNTARY PROGRAM IT'S
ENORMOUSLY SUCCESSFUL IN TERMS
OF ACTUALLY BUILDING AND
PROSPERITY IN THE PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT WOULD OTHERWISE WOULD
SEE THAT PROSPERITY.
AND I THINK WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
IT -- I WANT
TO JUST FOCUS ON THREE TRENDS
THAT WE'RE SEEING.
AND I THINK THAT.
ARE YOU KNOW I'VE I LIVED IN A
FORM OF DENIAL CLIMATE AND I'LL
FOR NUMBER OF YEARS I THOUGHT IF
WE WERE JUST REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS THAT WE WOULD PROBABLY
BE SUCCESSFUL IN AVOIDING THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND I THINK THE THAT IS VERY
CLEAR TO ME THAT WE'RE STARTING
TO SEE ROUTE THOROUGHLY UNTOWARD
WINDOW VANCE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT OUR STANDARDS.
DON'T REALLY MATCH THE NEW
CHALLENGES MRS IS IS PART OF THE
CHALLENGE OF HAVING TO A MORE
MODERN.
SAFETY PROGRAM THAN CURRENTLY
EXISTS.
WE HAVE TAKEN STEPS ALONG THAT
ROUTE SO FOR EXAMPLE RATHER THAN
JUST HAVING COMPLIANCE WITH
STANDARDS WHICH FORMS A CEILING.
ON SAFETY WE REQUIRED UTILITIES
TO EXPLAIN HOW THEIR
EXPENDITURES TARGET MAJOR RISKS.
AND ACTUALLY REDUCE THEM THAT
ACTUALLY COULD INCREASE THE
LEVEL OF SAFETY OVERTIME.
IT'S A WHICH IS A TOOL TO DRIVE
INNOVATION.
WE'RE STILL.
EARLY IN THE STAGE BUT WE THINK
THAT THAT'S A PATTERN FOR
SUCCESS.
WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO DO THING
AT THE C. P. U. C. AS A RATE
MAKING AGENCY WITH SAFETY AUDITS.
THAT'S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH BUT A ROUGH CALCULATION
OF WHAT IT WOULD TAKE TO
ACTUALLY DO.
AN ANNUAL INSPECTION OF ALL
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
FACILITIES.
CAME UP WITH SOME PLACE AROUND
TEN THOUSAND NEW EMPLOYEES AT
THE CPUC.
WE TAKE THAT DOWN TO A FIVE YEAR
CYCLE WHICH IS WHAT WE DO FOR
OUR PIPELINE SAFETY UNDER THE
FEDERAL --
PIPELINE HAZARDOUS MATERIAL
SAFETY AGENCIES RULES.
THEN IT WOULD STILL BE ABOUT
FIFTEEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES AT A
COST OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS.
SO I CAN SPEAK MORE TO THE
CHALLENGES AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT FOR A COUPLE OF
YEARS IN TERMS OF SAFETY BECAUSE
THIS IS --
THIS IS A BECAUSE THERE IS NO
STATEWIDE SAFETY AGENCY. ONE ONE
WE TEND TO USE NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES HOW DO WE DEVELOP
STANDARDS THAT ADDRESS THE THIS.
SPACE CLIMATE CHANGE THAT WERE
LIVING WITH I HATE TO TAKE CARE
OF YOUR RHYTHM INTERRUPT YOU
HERE BUT DO WE KNOW HOW MANY
EMPLOYEES OF THE UTILITIES WHOSE
PRINCIPAL JOB HISTORY.
THESE UTILITIES INTERNALLY.
AND HAVE IS THERE A WAY TO
SOMEHOW TO A SHIFT.
OF THOSE POSITIONS OVER TO THE
CPC IF IF YOU SEE A IN OUR A
CHALLENGES SENATOR IT'S TAKEN US
TWO YEARS TO GET AN EXTRA
HUNDRED SPACES FOR POLICE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO I DON'T KNOW WHAT
WE DO WITH TEN THOUSAND NO.
WORRIES.
BUT ARE THE THE THE EMPLOYEES
FOR THE UTILITIES.
FIRST OF ALL ARE THE THEIR
NUMBER TWO ARE THEY PERFORM SO
THIS IS SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING AT SEPARATELY AND SO
WE'VE DONE A A SAFETY AUDIT.
OCC CITY CULTURE ADDITIVE OF
FIVE P. JEANNIE AND I THINK THAT --
YOU HAVE PASSED US IN --
IN SB NINE A ONE OF REPLICATING
THAT FOR THE OTHER LARGE ARE YOU
ENERGY UTILITIES.
SO WHAT WE LEARNED IS THAT
BECAUSE THE NATURE OF THE HAZARD
HIS CHNGED IN THE THE OVERALL
RISK IS INCREASED BECAUSE OF
CHANGING CONDITIONS.
THE UTILITIES TEND.
TO AT LEAST P. JEANNIE TEND TO
USE A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
AND THEN WHEN THE AUDITOR'S ONE
OUT TO TALK TO SOME OF THE LINE
CREWS.
WHO I DO HAVE A LOT OF FAITH IN --
THEY REPORTED AS MANY AS
NINETEEN DIFFERENT SAFETY
PROGRAMS THAT THEY HAD TO COMPLY
WITH.
THAT BECOMES A CHALLENGE BECAUSE
IT'S SIMPLY VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PEOPLE TO AND REMEMBER ALL OF
THIS THE PROCESS STEPS THAT THEY
HAVE TO TAKE.
AND I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMIND OURSELVES IS SAFETY IS
TO IS NOT WHAT YOU THINK.
IT'S WHAT YOU DO.
IT'S THE THINGS YOU DO OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN SO WHEN YOU
GO TO VISIT A NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT.
WHERE A LOT OF THE PROGRAMS ARE
ACTUALLY VOLUNTARY BEST
PRACTICES ABOVE AND BEYOND AND
ARE SEIZE STANDARDS?
IT'S DEVELOPED THROUGH A UTILITY
PROGRAM CALLED IN PRO.
ANA INSTITUTE OF NUCLEAR POWER
OPERATORS.
THEY CONSTANTLY HER TRADING
INFORMATION WHEN SOMETHING
HAPPENS THAT THEY DON'T FEEL IS
A PROPER WAY THERE THERE'S AN
OUTAGE.
THAT ISN'T GOOD FOR DUE TO A NEW
SOURCE.
THEY ALL TALK ABOUT IT THEY ALL
THEY ALL TRY TO TAKE THAT
LEARNING AND TO INCORPORATE THAT
INTO THEIR DAILY PRACTICES THE
TRAIN FOR IT.
AND THEY MEMORIALIZES SO THAT IT
BECOMES NOT JUST WHAT THEY THINK
BUT WHAT THEY DO THEY PAY A LOT
OF ATTENTION TO WHAT PEOPLE
THINK.
BUT IT GOES MUCH DEEPER THAN
THAT AND SO THAT'S A CHALLENGE
THAT WE HAVE TO GET.
TO I'VE BEEN A IN IN OUR FIRST
AUDIT WHICH IS OF P. JEANNIE WE
FOUND THAT THE TOP LEADERSHIP
FRICKLEY WAS NOT.
AS FOCUSED AS WE THOUGHT THEY
NEEDED TO BE ON WHAT PEOPLE ARE
DOING THROUGHOUT THE
ORGANIZATION.
SO ON THE OTHER UTILITIES
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T YET CONDUCTED
THOSE AUDITS I CAN'T SAY.
I WILL SAYTHAT OVER AND OVER
AND OVER AGAIN WHEN AN EMERGENCY
COMES UP IT'S FREQUENTLY THE
LINE PERSONNEL WHO STEP UP USE
THEIR INITIATIVE.
AND AND TAKE THE RIGHT ACTIONS
ISSUES.
IS THE SAN BRUNO DISASTER WHERE
IT WAS A YARD SUPERVISOR WHO WAS
DRIVING IN HIS CAR.
KNEW EXACTLY WHERE THE VALVE WAS
A NEED TO BE TURNED OFF WENT TO
THE YARD GOT HIS TOOLS WENT
THERE AND DID IT MANUALLY
BECAUSE THE FOR ONE REASON OR
ANOTHER THE OPERATIONS CENTER.
WAS NOT WORKING THEY HAD NO
COMMUNICATION WITH FIELD THEY
HAD NO VISIBILITY ON WHERE THE
PROBLEM WAS HE JUST KNEW THAT
THERE WAS A PROBLEM.
SO I THINK THAT THAT THE SCALE
OF WHAT UTILITIES TO THE THE
AGING OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
ALSO CHANGING CONDITIONS IN
LARGE PARTS OF WHAT THEY DO THIS
IS THIS IS ALL IN SOME RESPECTS.
UNCHARTED TERRITORY.
AND THEN COME BACK TO WHAT I
THINK WE NEED TO DO BUT I THINK
THAT THAT SEE A LONGER
CONVERSATION AS WELL.
AND I THINK THAT IS A IT'S ALL
HAPPENING WITH IN THIS WORLD
WHERE THE NATURE OF THE ROLE OF
THE LEAST THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES
IS CHANGING.
AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT AS THEY GO
THROUGH THAT IT'S GOING TO BE-HARDER FOR THEM TO SOMETIMES
THINK ABOUT ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS.
PARTICULARLY TO LEADERSHIP LEVEL
[inaudible]
SO.
THAT'S A SECOND TOPIC THAT I
KNOW THE YEARS CONSIDERING
HAVING HEARING LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT THIS QUESTION OF
HOW CUSTOMERS DEPARTING FOR BOTH
NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
THAT'S ONE AXIS OF HOW PEOPLE
CUSTOMERS CAN MAKE CHOICES TO
PROVIDE THE ROLLER TRICITY.
BUT ALSO SOME FORD FOR DIFFERENT
BUSINESS MODELS THAT ARE OUT
THERE -- IN
I I ALSO SAY IS THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF INNOVATION AS HAVING A
DISCUSSION WITH THE CONSULTANT
TO THE TO THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
ASKING.
WHY SHOULD WE BE PREPARING FOR A
FUTURE THAT IS AUTONOMOUS
ELECTRIC VEHICLES WERE THE
INFRASTRUCTURES COULD LIKELY TO
BE THE AND BASED ON CORPORATION
ARCHER CENTRAL RECHARGE CHARGING?
OR SHOULD WE BE FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUAL OWNERSHIP OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES IN WHICH CASE IT'S
GOING TO BE A WORK PLACER IN
PLACE OF RESIDENCE.
THE THE THE WHERE SPENDING MONEY
THROUGH THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES
ARE SPENDING RATE PAYER DOLLARS
BASED ON AND DIRECTION THE THAT
THE LEGISLATURE GAVE US IN SB.
THREE FIFTY AND WE CAN SPEND A
LOT OF MONEY.
WAITING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
THESE INNOVATIONS ARE GONNA
BRING TO US IN TERMS OF THE WAY
THE TRANSPORTATION IS GOING TO
BE PLAYED OUT IN THE FUTURE --
ICE WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND AGAIN WE'RE NOT A
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY WE DON'T
REALLY KNOW WHERE PEOPLE GO.
WE JUST KNOW THE WHO WHAT WHERE
YOU'VE ASKED US TO DO WHICH IS
TO PROVIDE PARTICULAR KINDS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT IT
WE'RE NOT SURE WHAT THAT IS YET.
AND SO --
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT --
THAT THERE OF DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES PEOPLE IN WHO DEPART
FURTHER AND FURTHER AND FURTHER
FROM LAND LINE PHONES.
TOWARDS CELL PHONES TRYING TO
GIVE WARNINGS FOR EXAMPLE DURING
DISASTERS HAS BECOME PROBLEMATIC
WE HOPE TO HAVE A MEMO TO YOU
FAIRLY SOON THE THAT SYNTHESIZES
SOME OF THE DIFFERENT REPORTS
WE'VE SEEN FROM WILDFIRES AND
AND AND AND FLOOD DISASTERS.
LESS THAN 50% OF THE FOLKS WHO
ON THE COUNTY.
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES IN
AND SONOMA TRACKED IN THEIR TEST
ACTUALLY GOT ANY OF THE WARNINGS
THAT THE COUNTY PUT OUT.
SO WE COULD REQUIRE THE
UTILITIES TO DO THIS BUT I GIVEN
THAT THE WAY THE YOU REACH
PEOPLE IS THROUGH THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THAT'S GOING
TO ACTUALLY DO WHAT WE NEED TO
HAVE DONE.
AND SO I AS WE LEARN MORE ABOUT
SAFETY A GROW INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED.
THAT THE CPC IS NOT AS PREPARED
AS WE SHOULD BE.
BUT I ALSO HAVE THIS FEELING
THAT THEIR BIG GAP BETWEEN STATE
AGENCIES BETWEEN INDUSTRIES AND
AND THERE'S NOT THAT CENTRAL
SAFETY --
ENTITY IN THE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THEY CAN GIVE US
DIRECTION [inaudible]
SO ON I DON'T KNOW IF ANYBODY
ELSE WANTS TO JUMP IN OTHERWISE
I WOULD JUST GO ON TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
OUR IMPLEMENTATION OF SB NINE A
ONE WE HAVE A CHART HERE.
WHICH IS BEHIND ME SO I MAY BE
HARD FOR SOME OF YOU TO SEE BUT
I THINK WE ALSO GAVE YOU
HANDOUTS.
SO FROM YOU BE FINALIZED THE
LEGISLATION IN OCTOBER THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED IT BECAME
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST AND WE
REALLY JUMPED IN --
TO TO TO OUR PLAY WE WANTED TO
REALLY KIND OF FOCUS ON GETTING
CORD PIECES DONE.
BEFORE THIS SUMMER'S FIRE SEASON.
SO WE IMMEDIATELY --
CREATED DAY PROCEEDING TO LOOK
AT THE STRESS TEST THE YOU
INCLUDED IN SB NINE A ONE WE
HAVE BEEN AUGMENTING THE PRE
MANAGEMENT PLANS WE GOT THE
FIRST ROUND OF THE NEW.
WILDFIRE MANAGEMENT PLANS WERE
YOU WE'VE JOINED WITH CAL FIRE
TO ACTUALLY REVIEW THOSE PLANS.
WE HOPE TO ADOPT THEM IN TIME
FOR THE UTILITIES TO ACTUALLY
CONTINUE ACTING ON THEM FOR
THROUGH THE THE THE SUMMER.
WITH DAN VERY ENERGETIC IN TERMS
OF WHAT.
ADDITIONAL THINGS WE NEED TO DO
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE THE THE
VICTIMS OF DISASTERS --
SO I'LL JUST KIND REFER YOU TO
THIS CHART WERE GRINDING THROUGH
ALL THESE THINGS IT'S IT'S A
BURDEN ON US.
OUT OF OUR FORTY JUDGES SEVEN
THE NUMBER ASSIGNED FULL TIME TO
THESE PROCEEDINGS --
THAT MEANS THAT OTHER THINGS
PROBABLY WON'T GET DONE AT THE
PACE THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
THEM DONE.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY ANALYSTS SO
FOR EXAMPLE ON LOOKING AT A WILD
FIRE MANAGEMENT PLAN WE CAN
CHECK THE BOXES. TO SAY THAT
THESE ARE THE THINGS YOU TOLD US
THE PLAN SHOULD INCLUDE.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE MEANINGFUL
EXPERTISE IN FIRES IN FIRE
MANAGEMENT TO REALLY SAY WHETHER
THIS IS GOING TO ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THE KIND OF SAFETY THAT
WE ALL EXPECT TO SEE.
WERE WORKING CLOSELY WITH CAL
FIRE WE HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
THEM FOR THEIR PERSONAL TO HELP
US EVALUATE THAT SO I THINK
WE'LL GET AMOUNT TIMELY.
BUT AGAIN I THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S
ONE OF THOSE ISSUES IN TERMS OF
WHAT OUR SKILL SETS ARE WHAT THE
WHAT THE LAW HAS ASKED US TO DO
IN THE PAST.
IN THE NATURE OF THE CHANGING
WORLD THAT WERE IN SO HAPPY TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS.
I JUST.
WANTED TO COME BACK TO THE ISSUE
OF THE TIMING OF THE RATE CASES
BECAUSE HERE WERE OF OF THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT WERE WORKING
HARD TO ADDRESS SAFETY ISSUES
RELATED TO THE WIRE WILD FRES
AND WORKING TO HARD DARK RED.
AND FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND THAT
COMES FROM.
THE THE A BUDGET BUDGETS A
KAMADO OF THE THE RATE CASES.
AND WHEN I HEAR FOR YEARS ON A
ON A CASE IT JUST STARTED IN
JANUARY --
IT SOUNDS LIKE [inaudible]
WE'RE NOT [inaudible]
IMMEDIATELY RESPOND.
BEING RESPONSIVE TO KIND OF THE
THREAD AND HAND.
IS THERE A WAY TO AS WE GO
THROUGH THIS PROCESS SEEK TO
ADDRESS KIND OF THE THREAT TO
THE RATE CASE ALLOW SOME KIND OF
DECISIONS TO BE MADE.
EITHER X. YOU KNOW.
SHORTEN.
THE DECISION PROCESS AND I KNOW
THAT.
IS IT SEEMS EASY FOR ME SET UP
HERE JUST KIND OF WELL TO A
AGAIN OUT ALL OFFERS I HAVE IN
THE PAST IF YOU WANT TO GET
THESE THINGS OUT FASTER MAKE A
SINGLE DECISION MAKER WILL SPEED
RIGHT THROUGH IT.
BUT THERE'S THIS TENSION BETWEEN
DEMOCRACY YEAH AND THE INTEREST
IN ACTUALLY HAVING A LOT OF
PEOPLE BE ABLE TO SATISFY THEM
FOR THEMSELVES THAT THESE OR ARE
WISE EXPENDITURES.
VERSUS SPEED WHAT WE DO DO IS WE
ALLOW THE UTILITIES TO MAKE
THOSE EXPENDITURES AND RECORD
THEM IN SPECIAL ACCOUNTING.
OF POOLS WHICH WE CALL YOU THE
CATASTROPHIC REALLY YOU CAN MAKE
DECISIONS AND WE ON ROOM THAT
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN AND AS A
MATTER OF FACT WE HAVE AS THEY
COME FORWARD TO US AND SAY WE
THINK WE NEED TO BEGIN SPENDING
MONEY NOW.
WILL OPEN UP THAT THAT THAT
COUNTY AND SAY OKAY FINE GO
AHEAD AND SAY HAS A REQUEST.
THAT BE DONE OR YOU CAN RICK
QUEST THEM DOES COME BACK WITH
SOMETHING THAT WE DON'T CUT
CORNERS ANYMORE.
YOUR VIEW OF WHAT YOU TOLD US IN
MANY WAYS WE NEED TO BE
TRANSPARENT THIS IS HOW WE MAKE
THAT TRANSPARENT.
BUT WHAT I'M SAYING IS --
IN OTHER WORDS HOW DO WE ON THE
MY QUESTION IS JUST WHAT STARTS
UP PROCESS.
USUALLY THEY TELL US THAT
THEY'RE READY TO START SPENDING
THROUGH APPLICATION OF I'LL JUST
PASS IT OFF DEAD SINCE HE
ACTUALLY HANDLES THAT WARRANT A
MINISTERIAL LEVEL WE DO TAKE A
VOTE ON IT.
AGAIN BECAUSE YOU'VE TOLD US TO
BE TRANSPARENT AND THAT'S AND
ALL THAT IS FINE.
I'M.
YEAH NOT TO GET TOO IN THE
TECHNICAL TERMS OF A GENERAL
RATE CASES BUT YET IF THE%
UTILITY WANTS TO DO I'D I'D
SPENDING --
BETWEEN RATE CASES SO IT'S
SPENDING A PROGRAM THAT WAS NOT
APPROVED IN THE LAST RATE CASE --
WHAT THEY CAN DO IS I CAN COME
IN AND REQUEST OPEN WHAT'S
CALLED A MEMORANDUM ACCOUNT?
INTO FOR EXAMPLE ON THE SAFETY
RELATED SPENDING TO THE WILD
FIRES.
I SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON --
OF MAIL FROM LAST YEAR ACTUALLY
SUBMITTED AN APPLICATION AND
SAID WE WANT --
WE HAVE A PLAN TO DO FOR OF
THEIR LINE SO THAT THEIR MORE
FIRE RESISTANT.
ON IN AS PART OF THAT IF WE
APPROVE THAT PLAN AND THEY WOULD
ALSO BE AUTHORIZED TO GO AHEAD
AND COLLECT THE MONEY AND RATES
FOR THAT --
WITH THE WILD FOR MITIGATION
PLANS THE STATUTE ACTUALLY SAYS
THE A WIN YOU APPROVE YOU SEE
WHEN YOU APPROVED THE PLANS.
ALSO APPROVED A MEMORANDUM
ACCOUNT THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
START COLLECTING --
ARE ACTUALLY NOT CASE ALLOW THEM
TO START BY TRACKING THE COST --
AND THEN IN THE NEXT GENERATE
CASE OR IN ANOTHER PROCEEDING
DEPENDING UPON TIMING IN ISSUES
WE WOULD GO BACK AND LOOK AT THE
REASONABLENESS OF THE COST --
SO IN THOSE CASES WHERE THEY
NEED TO SPEND ON SOMETHING
BETWEEN GENERATE CASES THERE'S A
MECHANISM OUT THERE FOR THEM TO
START TRACKING THE COST RIGHT
AWAY.
AND THEN WE WOULD DO --
A REVIEW OF THE REASON ON THIS
OF THE EXPENSES OF LATER ON IN
THE PROCESS OKAY.
I WILL GO TO SENATOR DODD
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR RUBIO AND
THEN WE HAVE HILTON AND STERN
[inaudible]
OKAY -- IF
YOU.
OKAY TO PARK TO PART QUESTION --
ONE JUST EXPOUNDING ON THAT RATE
CASE -- WORD
OF PROCESS RIGHT NOW ON A RATE
CASE OR OR SOME RULE MAKING --
FOR THE NINE OH ONE WE CALL
REPAIR REPAIR PROTECTION.
BONDS CRACKED.
IT I'M ASSUMING.
I'LL JUST AYE I'M ASSUMING THAT
PROBABLY SINCE THEY'RE A
BANKRUPTCY.
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY.
NOT A PRIORITY ANY LONGER OR IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT KNOWS
PROCEEDING NO I SPENT THE
WEEKEND READING PEOPLE'S REPLY
COMMENTS ON ON THAT SO IT'S
UNDER WAY WE HOPE TO HAVE A
METHODOLOGY.
THE PEOPLE CAN SEE.
SET THE CHALLENGES THAT WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE COSTS ARE THE WITH
BOND.
FOR ALL YOU HAVE IS REALLY ROUGH
ESTIMATES USUALLY WHEN.
YOU DO A RECOVERY ACTION.
YOU COME FORWARD TO THE P. YOU
IN C. AND SAID.
HERE'S WHAT WE HAD TO PAY OUT TO
SETTLE ALL THESE CLAIMS AGAINST
THIS SOMETIMES THE UTILITY.
JUST HAS TO PAY CLAIM SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEIR EQUIPMENT.
BECAUSE THE PROBLEM.
THERE'S NOT A A A A THEY COLLECT
NECESSARILY FOR A A FAILURE TO
OBSERVE STANDARDS IT JUST
HAPPENED.
THAT'S INVERSE CONDEMNATION
THEY'RE THE FIRST PAY ARE THEY
CAN COLLECT FROM INSURANCE
COMPANIES THEIR INSURANCE
COMPANIES SOMETIMES OTHER
PARTIES WHO CONTRIBUTED.
EXAMPLE WOULD BE THE MALIBU FIRE
TWO YEARS AGO THEY WERE CAUSED
BY A TELEPHONE COMPANIES
EQUIPMENT ON THE POLLS. FOR A
SIMILAR CASE WERE CABLE COMPANY
AND SAN DIEGO DID THAT IN THE
TWO THOUSAND THREE FIRES SO
THEY'LL COLLECT ALL THAT MONEY.
THEY'LL THEY'LL USE THEIR OWN
INSURANCE POOL THEN I'LL COME
AND SAY HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN WHAT WE HAD TO PAY OUT.
AND WHAT IT COST FOR US TO TO
PAY ALL THESE CLAIMS.
WE PERFORM A REASONABLENESS TEST
YOU CHANGED THE RULES FOR US FOR
CLIMATE RELATED FIRES.
SO WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF DOING
THAT YOU ALSO HAVE ALLOWED THEM.
THEN TO SECURITIZED THE COST
RATHER THAN DUMPING IT ALL INTO
RATE PAYERS IN A SINGLE YEAR SEE
YOU SPREAD IT OUT OVER YOU OVER
SEVERAL YEARS.
IT MAKES IT A LITTLE EASIER FOR
THEM TO SATISFY ALL THEIR OTHER
CREDITORS AT THE SAME TIME
BECAUSE NOT ALL THEIR CASH GETS
TIED UP IN THAT ONE TOOL WE'RE
TRYING TO DEVELOP THAT
METHODOLOGY IF YOU COME FORWARD
WITH THE CLAIM.
HERE'S HOW WE WOULD EVALUATE
WHAT YOU WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
VERSUS WHAT RATE PAYERS WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE.
FOR UNDER THE NEW TEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE GAVE US IN SB NINE A
ONE REALLY IT'S TO QUESTION I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SECOND --
PART OF THAT QUESTION AND I'LL
GET TO MY LAST ONE IS.
YOU INDICATED A ONE OF THE
MEETINGS THAT PERHAPS --
THE CBC MAY HAVE THE ABILITY IN
THE FUTURE.
ON THAT GO TO HOLD TO BE ABLE TO
APPLY THAT --
ELSEWHERE.
IN JUST READING BETWEEN THE
LINES WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW.
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
NST GT.
THAT MAY BE SOMETHING.
THAT MIGHT BE APPROPRIATE DO YOU
HAVE YOU DONE WORK WITH YOUR
ATTORNEYS OR ANY.
TO HAVE ANY FURTHER --
OPINION ON THAT WE'VE WE'VE
WE'VE DONE THAT I UNDERSTAND
THAT ARE THAT SOME OF OUR STAFF
IT HAD CONVERSATION WITH
LEGISLATIVE STAFF WHO BELIEVE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THAT
AUTHORITY THAT'S THE PAIN OF
SOME OF MY ATTORNEYS.
SO OUT OF AN ABUNDANCE QUIT
SAYING THAT --
IF IN FACT THE LEGISLATURE WOULD
LIKE FOR US TO APPLY THE SAME
TESS IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THEN I WAS
SO HOPE THE WILL GIVE US OF
PERMISSION TO DO THAT.
IS -- AT
THIS POINT IS VERY CLOUDY AND WE
KEEP GETTING MIX I KEEP GETTING
MIXED MESSAGES FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
JUST JUST A POINT OF CLARITY
HERE SO --
AS AS YOU VERY WELL KNOW IS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL ON THERE'S
PROVISIONS THAT DEAL WITH WILD
FIRES IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THEIR
PROVISION TO DEAL WITH WILD
FIRES IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AND FORWARD AND THERE IS --
THE IT DOES THE BILL DOES NOT
DIRECTLY ADDRESS ANYTHING.
FOR WILDFIRES WOULD HAPPEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ON AS FAR
AS THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
SECURITIZATION F OF COSTS TO
ALLOW THE UTILITY TO GO OUT AND
DO A REDDIQUETTE DEDICATED RATE
COMPONENT.
AND COLLECT COSTS THAT WE
AUTHORIZED EITHER BECAUSE THEY
WERE PRUDENT --
OR BECAUSE THEY WERE ABOUT S.
THRESHOLD ON THE STATUTORY
AUTHORITIES VERY EXPLICITLY FOR
WILDFIRES IN --
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHERE
THERE'S SOME QUESTION ON WHERE
OUR AUTHORITY IS IS THAT ABILITY
TO APPLY THE NEW.
NC STANDARDS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED AND AND SB
NINE A ONE AS IT RELATES.
TO TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN BECAUSE
WE'VE ALWAYS HAD SOME
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW WE DEFINE --
PRUDENCE HE THERE IS SOME
QUESTION IF WE GOT A PROCEEDING
TO LOOK AT THE FOR AND SEE OF IT
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WILDFIRE.
WHAT WITH THE STANDARDS WE USE
THEIR AND COULD WE USE --
THE STANDARDS IN THE BILL EVEN
THOUGH THOSE STANDARDS --
WERE DRAFTED FOR TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN AND BEYOND WHAT'S
YOUR OPINION ON THAT.
I THINK I WILL ON THE STICK WITH
PRESENT PICKERS POINT THAT THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME DIVIDED --
OPINION ON THAT --
I WILL SAY WE DO HAVE BROAD
AUTHORITY ON ON HOW WE DEFINE
FOR AGENCY AND WE COULD LOOK AT
IT BROADER THAN WE HAVE IN THE
PAST.
YEAH MY SUGGESTION IS YOU MAY
NEED THAT BEFORE --
THE LEGISLATURE IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO APPLY ON THAT BUT THAT
IS ONLY POSSIBLE BUT HERE'S MY
FEARS GIVEN THE CLOUDY ANSWERS
THAT WE RECEIVED ALL AROUND.
IT'S PRETTY LIKELY THAT THIS
WILL BE THE CPUC IN THE COURTS.
AND IF MARKETS ARE LOOKING FOR
CERTAINTY.
THAT IS NOT GONNA SARACENIC GIVE
THEM WITH ME IF I COULD BUILD ON
THAT I MEAN THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE
RATING AGENCIES SAY RIGHT NOW.
ON IS THEY NEED MORE CERTAINTY
AROUND THE DECISION MAKING
PROCESS ON COST RECOVERY.
ON IN WE CAN'T PROVIDE THAT
CERTAINTY UNTIL THERE'S AN
ACTUAL APPLICATION PROCEED IN
FRONT OF US.
SO A QUICKER WAY TO PROVIDE MORE
CERTAINTY WOULD BE THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE FAIR ENOUGH I
APPRECIATE STRAIGHT ANSWERS I
REALLY DO --
FINALLY MISTER CHAIR --
YOU INDICATED EARLIER THAT --
THE TO SEE IF YOU SEE DOES NOT
HAVE THE EXPERTISE IN TERMS OF
YOUR VALIDATING ELISE RIGHT NOW
VALIDATING WHETHER --
I WANT TO PUT WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH BUT IT WAS --
YOUR REGARDING SAFETY --
WE'RE NOT GONNA PUT ON THOUSANDS
OF EMPLOYEES.
IN NO MATTER WHAT WE'RE NOT
GONNA DO THAT SOON ENOUGH.
YOU KNOW TO BE ABLE TO MAKE --
TO MAY BE ABLE TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE I GUESS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE IS.
RIGHT NOW WE GOT A SITUATION
WHERE PGE PRIVILEGE ISSUES P.
GENIE IS AN EXAMPLE.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
DETERMINING WHAT WORK NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
THEY'RE THE ONES THAT DO THE
WORK.
AND THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
CERTIFIED THAT THE WORK HAS BEEN
DONE.
AND THEY GIVE YOU THAT
INFORMATION AND YOU AUDIT.
THAT TO ME SOUNDS IT IN THE
CONTEXT OF WHERE WE ARE TODAY
BEING A MONDAY MORNING
QUARTERBACKS REALLY EASY.
AND NOBODY EVER THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS. THREE OR FOUR FIVE YEARS
AGO SO I TOTALLY GET THAT.
BUT THAT SOUNDS PRETTY CRAZY TO
ME AND I GUESS WHAT I'M
WONDERING IS.
WHAT ABOUT HAVING IT?
SAID YOU DON'T HAVE THAT
EXPERTISE IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
CAL FIRE DOES WE HAVE A CONTRACT
WITH CAL FIRE HELP IS TO REVIEW
THE PLAN IS SO IF THEY'VE GOT
THE EMPLOYEES ARE GOING OUT
THERE AND AUDITING THEIR OWN
STUFF.
WHAT DID I THINK THE --
THE CHAIRMAN WAS GOV.
SAYING SOMETHING LIKE THIS WHAT
ABOUT TRANSFERRING THE THOSE --
**** MEETING --
LABOR [inaudible]
FROM.
PGA IN THE COST OF THAT THE
CALIFORNIA HAVE A THIRD PARTY.
OVERSIGHT OF YOU KNOW THE
TRIMMING OF THESE TREES TO MAKE
SURE THEY'RE DONE SAFELY BECAUSE
WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE.
TO GET THAT FROM.
THE POWERS THAT THAT THEY BE
GIVEN THE P. JEANNIE THAT WE CAN
COUNT.
SO I'M NOT GONNA SAY THAT THAT
WOULDN'T BE A STEP FORWARD BUT
I'LL JUST SAY THAT IF YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIS HOLISTICALLY I
THINK THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL
OTHER PIECES THAT WE REALLY NEED
TO THINK ABOUT.
SO WE LEARNED THE HARD WAY.
WHAT WOULD IT TAKE FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO HAVE?
THE CAPACITY TO ACTUALLY LOOK
FOR PROBLEMS THAT ARE EMERGING.
AND TO BEGIN TO SAY OKAY.
WE NEED TO REALLY BEGIN TO
ADDRESS THE WAY THINGS ARE
DIFFERENT.
OF WE ARE HAVING MORE.
PRECIPITATION FALL IS RAIN
RATHER THAN SNOW.
IN ALL OF THE STANDARDS FOR OUR
DAM SAFETY AND ARE DAM OPERATION --
BUILT AROUND. TWO HUNDRED YEARS
OF METEOROLOGY THAT ASSUME TO
HIRES THE SNOW PACK.
IN LESS WAS FREE REIGN WHAT DO
WE DO THEN TO DEVELOP NEW
STANDARDS WHEN WE HAVE STANDARDS
WE TEND TO USE NATIONAL
STANDARDS SO FOR EXAMPLE OUR
PIPELINE AND HAZARDOUS SAFETY
MATERIALS --
PARTNERS AT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY TAKE OUR
FOLKS TRAIN THEM AND WE USE
THEIR STANDARDS SO FOR EXAMPLE
WHEN A NEW HOUSE OR LIKE.
A GAS STORAGE FACILITY WHERE THE
PROBLEM IS WELLS WHICH WE DON'T
HAVE ANY AUTHORITY AND HE COMES
UP.
WE SORT OF DEPEND ON THEM AND
DOGGER TO DEVELOP NEW RULES THAT
WE ENFORCE FOR THE UTILITIES HOW
DO WE GET AHEAD OF THAT AND HOW
DO WE DEVELOP THOSE NEW
STANDARDS.
SO THOSE ARE TWO COMPONENTS.
THEN THE THIRD PIECE OF IT IS
HOW DO YOU POLICE.
WERE IN AUDITING AGENCY BECAUSE
WERE RATE MAKING AGENCY.
THOSE ARE THE TOOLS WHEN WE
STARTED WE HAD ENGINEERS AND
ACCOUNTANTS.
AND THAT'S BEEN THE TRADITION IF
YOU WANT IS TO HAVE THAT
POLICING POWER WHICH IS WHAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S THE WRONG
THING TO DO BUT I WILL ALSO I'LL
JUST A LEAVE IT TO YOU IN YOUR
EXAMINATION AS TO WHETHER IT
SHOULD BE IN THE CPUC.
OR I TO BE IN SOME KIND OF A
SAFETY THEN YOU NEED A REAL
ENFORCEMENT GRADUATED
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM WE'RE
STRUGGLING TO DEVELOP THAT WE
HAVE INCOMPLETE CITATION AREA.
AUTHORITY FOR DIFFERENT KINDS OF
UTILITIES WE HAVE IT FOR SOME
BUT NOT FOR OTHERS.
AND THEN.
THEN YOU START TO ACTUALLY HAVE
WHAT I THINK MOST PEOPLE'S
IMAGES AND EXPECTATIONS OF THE
SAFETY AGENCY ARE.
WHAT WE DO IS THE BACK UP THAT
RATE MAKING THAT WE DO WE GO OUT
TO ACTUALLY AUDIT?
BOOKS TO SEE IF THEY SPENT THE
MONEY THE WAY THEY SAID THE DEAL
WITH THE BOOKS WORK AND THEN WE
DO SPOT CHECKS. TO SEE WHETHER
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THE FIELD.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE ALWAYS DONE
THAT'S WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ASKED US TO DO.
IF YOU WANT TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT GOD BLESS TELUS
[inaudible]
THE NEW.
THANK YOU --
THANK YOU FOR THAT INFORMATION
I'M AT TAKE A LITTLE BIT --
BACK.
IN THE SAME VEIN AS THOSE
QUESTIONS FOR YEARS YOU SAY YOU
HAD A FIRST AUDIT THAT FOUND
THAT DOT THE LEADERSHIP WASN'T
DOING OR WASN'T FOCUSED ON WHAT
THE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON CAN
YOU EXPAND ON THAT AND GIVE US
SOME EXAMPLES OF WHAT YOU MEAN.
SO AFTER THE THE SAN BRUNO
EXPLOSION --
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT HAPPENS SOME
OF THAT'S ON THE TECHNICAL LEVEL.
BUT WE ACTUALLY S. AN
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL OF NOT
JUST LOOK AT P. JEANNIE BUT TO
LOOK AT THE CPSC. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY EMPHASIZE WAS
THE IMPORTANCE OF SAFETY CULTURE.
AND THAT'S KIND OF A HARD THING
TO REALLY QUANTIFY IT'S A
QUALITATIVE SET OF BEHAVIORS.
SO WE HIRED A FIRM OUT OF NEW
YORK THAT HAS DONE A VARIETY OF
CORPORATE AUDITS INCLUDING
SAFETY AUDITS THEY'RE CALLED
NORTH STAR I GOT THEIR NAME FROM
THE THE COMMISSIONERS AND IN NEW
YORK OUR TREES OF WOMAN.
AND WE ASK THEM TO GO THROUGH
AND JUST DO A THOROUGH GOING
PROGRAM AUDIT.
OF THE SAFETY PROGRAMS AT P.
JEANNIE US BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
THEY ACTUALLY CARRIED OUT SAFETY
ON A DAY TO DAY.
BASIS IF YOU'RE AN AUDIT AGENCY
YOU'RE LOOKING AT EXPENDITURES
AND ACTUALLY THE SCOPE OF THE
PROGRAMS.
THAT DOESN'T TELL YOU WHAT
PEOPLE DO.
DOESN'T TELL YOU HOW THE THEY DO
IT AND WE WANTED TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT WAS HAPPENING ON
THE GROUND.
SO WE CAN'T WE GOT WE GOT A
FAIRLY --
SIGNIFICANT REPORT ABOUT A YEAR
AND EIGHT MONTHS AGO THAT THAT
BASICALLY SAID.
THAT THERE WERE A VARIETY OF
PROBLEMS AT EVERY LEVEL WITHIN
P. JEANNIE IN TERMS OF SAFETY
AND ONE OF THEM WAS THAT THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS ITSELF WAS
NOT ASKING A LOT OF QUESTIONS
AND NOT BEING PERSISTENT.
THEY HAD A SAFETY COMMITTEE.
IT WAS THE NUCLEAR AND AND
SAFETY COMMITTEE AND THEY
ACTUALLY DID TRACK THINGS.
BUT THEY WEREN'T ASKING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS NOR WAS THE REST OF
THE BOARD ASKING A LOT OF
QUESTIONS SO THAT'S A SIGN THE
DIRECTORS PROBLEM PARTICULARLY
AFTER THE SAN BRUNO [inaudible]
EXPLOSION.
IN IN TO THIS DAY --
POINTED THIS OUT PUBLICLY FIVE
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTOR MEMBERS
OF P. JEANNIE ARE ACTUALLY ON
THE BOARD WERE ON THE BOARD AT
THE TIME SEEMED BURNER STILL
THERE.
THAT'S SINCE THIS MESSAGE WITHIN
THE ORGANIZATION ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
IT THAT THAT THE AT THE TIRES
LEVELS PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
YOU KNOW ANOTHER THING THAT I'VE
I'VE POINTED OUT IS THAT THE
THEN CEO PETER DAR RETIRED
RETIRED WITH A THIRTY EIGHT
DOLLAR A RETIREMENT BONUS MOSTLY
BECAUSE IN.
TERMS OF SHARES. TWENTY AUTHORS
THIRTY EIGHT YOU SAID --
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION SORRY
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO THERE IS THAT LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AT THE BOARD IN
THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL THEN WE JUST
DISCOVERED THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT
THEY'VE ADOPTED.
BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR TO THEM OR TO
US WHICH ARE THE ONES THAT ARE
WORKING MOST EFFECTIVELY.
SO IT IS A IN IN THE ONE OF THE
THE AUDITOR'S SAID TO ME THEY
WERE JUST TAKING EVERY GOOD IDEA
THE SOMEBODY CAME UP WITH IT AND
TRYING IT.
BUT WITHOUT THE TOOLS IN PLACE
TO HELP THEM UNDERSTAND WHICH
WERE EFFECTIVE WHEN WE'RE NOT
AFFECTIVE.
AND SO THAT TO ME IS IS IS
ANOTHER SET OF CHALLENGES THAT
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS.
THEY THEY THAT I I'LL BE HAPPY
TO SEND YOU THE REPORT IT'S
CLASSIC COVERS ABOUT HUNDRED
FORTY PAGES IT'S VERY COMPLETE.
WE ASKED WE ACTUALLY MADE A
SERIES OF RECOMMENDATIONS BUT WE
ALSO HAVE BEEN PERSISTENT IN
ASKING QUESTIONS WE CONTINUE TO
FIND AT THEIR LEADERSHIP
PROBLEMS WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION --
AND SO WE'RE NOW AT THE POINT
WHAT'S THE RIGHT REMEDY.
AND WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU FIND
THAT KIND OF OF OF CHALLENGES
WITHIN AN ORGANIZATION. FIVE
YEARS AFTER THE END STARTED THIS
PROCESS.
IT'S IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
TO HAVE A GOOD RECORD AND TO
PROVE THAT THAT ADDITIONAL STEPS
ARE NECESSARY BECAUSE WERE
PROCEDURAL ORGANIZATION WE HAVE
TO BE TRANSPARENT WE CAN'T MAKE.
IMPORTANT CHANGES TO A LARGE
CORPORATION WITHOUT HAVING A
GOOD BASIS FOR DOING.
NOW THE QUESTION IS.
WHAT WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE AND
ACTUALLY IMPROVE SAFETY?
WHAT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO AND
WE'VE HAD I'D SEE OTHER THING I
SPENT THE WEEKEND READING IS IS
COMMENTS IN THE SAFETY CULTURE
AUDIT OF P. JEANNIE.
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE GONE SO FAR AS
TO PROPOSE MUNICIPAL IS ATION OF
THE COMPANY BREAKING IT UP INTO
SMALLER UNITS SEPARATING OFF THE
GAS UTILITY PUTTING PUBLIC
MEMBERS ON THE BOARDS?
SO WE HAVE SUCH A ROBUST ENOUGH --
ON THE RECORD NOW THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY START TO ANALYZE IT TO
MAKE SUGGESTIONS I SUSPECT THAT
THEY WILL BE VERY SIMILAR TO THE
KINDS OF ISSUES ON A RISE IN THE
GOVERNOR SIXTY DAY PLAN OR IN
THE BANKRUPTCY.
SO SAID TO HELP A LITTLE BIT
JUST REAL QUICK YOU SAID
BEHAVIORS ARE HARD TO QUANTIFY
BUT YOU JUST I THINK YOU
DISCUSSED NINETEEN PROGRAMS THAT
WERE ADOPTED THAT YOU SAID THAT
THEY HAD TO COMPLY WITH --
ARE THOSE PROGRAMS ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT ALL THE GREAT
IDEAS THAT PEOPLE PUT TOGETHER
AS MANY THAT WORK IS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO MANY AS NINETEEN
PROGRAMS AND BUT THE THE
CHALLENGE BECOMES IS IT MAYBE
SOME OF THEM DO WORK.
BUT IF YOU HAVE TO THINK OF
NINETEEN DIFFERENT CHECKLIST
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE FIELD
[inaudible]
SOMETIMES.
MORE IS ACTUALLY LESS.
BECAUSE YOU'RE MAKING QUICK
DECISIONS.
ON THE BEST WAY TO CLAMP DOWNA
LEAKING --
PLASTIC GAS PIPE.
SO YOU WANT TO HAVE THE SAFETY
PROGRAMS SAFETY PROTOCOLS THE
CHECKLIST.
SET OF BEHAVIORS THAT YOU EMPLOY
IN THAT SITUATION PRETTY CLEAR.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE PEOPLE
TRYING TO IS SHOULD BE DOING
THIS CHECKLIST --
THAT CHECKLIST REAL QUICKLY SO
WHO'S CHECKING ON THOSE --
NINETEEN LESS IS THERE SOMEONE
THAT'S VETTING THEM TO SEE WHAT
WORKS WHAT DOESN'T WORK AND YOU
JUST SAID A RIGHT NOW HAVING TOO
MANY DOESN'T SEEM TO WORK BEST A
WHOSE.
WEAVING THEM OUT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE A CONTRACT WITH
NORTHSTAR THEY HAVE THE
EXPERTISE IN SOME OF THESE
THINGS WE ALSO ARE DEVELOPING
SKILLS WITHIN OUR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION BUT I'LL
JUST SAY THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH
WORK INDUSTRIES THAT RANGE FROM --
TRANSPORTATION NET -
COMPANIES --
TO CHARTER PARTY CARRIERS BUSES
TO TELCOS WITH DIFFERENT KINDS
OF REGULATION TO ELECTRIC
UTILITIES TO GAS UTILITIES.
SO.
AGAIN HAVING THAT DEEP EXPERTISE
IN THE BEST KIND OF SAFETY
PROGRAM WHAT THE NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES ARE.
WILL BE TOUGH AND I'LL TELL YOU
THAT FOR THE KIND OF FIRES THAT
WE'RE SEEING.
THERE ARE NO BEST PRACTICES
ELSEWHERE WE STE THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT WE CAN TALK TO HAVE THE
SAME KIND OF EXPERIENCES WITH AS
WE DO OUR THE AUSTRALIANS.
SO WHAT DO YOU DO WHEN YOU'RE
OUT THERE ON THE CUTTING EDGE
AND YOU COULD YOU THE ONLY WAY
YOU'RE GOING.
BY EXPERIENCE OF THOSE ARE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE
INTERNALLY ON THIS STUFF THERE'S
NOT A OFF THE SHELF SOLUTION.
THAT WE CAN FIND.
THANK YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU
TERM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I'VE GOT
THREE QUESTIONS INTO WHO WERE
ACTUALLY FOLLOWS FROM THE
SENATOR RUBIO AND SENATOR DODD.
OF IT IS YOU KNOW THE OF I'VE
HAD A STRONG OPINION ON THE
MANDATORY REPORTING ISSUE THAT --
CAME ABOUT LAST YEAR ON ELECTRIC
AND GAS UTILITIES IF YOU ADOPTED.
IT CREATED AS YOU KNOW REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR POTENTIAL
VIOLATIONS WHICH FELL INTO TWO
CATEGORIES MANDATORY REPORTING
OF THE POTENTIAL VIOLATION.
POSES A SIGNIFICANT SAFETY
THREAT TO THE PUBLIC OR UTILITY
STAFF.
AT INVOLUNTARY REPORTING FOR
POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS THAT
BECAUSE SYSTEM WIDE IMPACTION
IT'S JUST THE FRAUD AND OTHER
THINGS BUT HOW HAVE THE
UTILITIES BEEN EXERCISING THESE
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND AND
HOW HAS THE S. P. D. BEEN
TRACKING.
WHAT HAS BEEN REPORTED IN THOSE?
SO I'LL I'LL JUST GIVE A TOP
LINE AND AND MINUTE PANDA LEE IF
YOU WE NEED TO GO DEEPER IT'S
MAY THIRTY FIRST OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN WE ACTUALLY RECORD.
OF FOR GAS POTENTIAL VIOLATIONS
IN THE FOR ELECTRIC VIOLATIONS.
OF THE GAS VIOLATIONS ONE WAS
VOLUNTARY THREE WERE MANDATORY.
OF THE ELECTRIC.
SEVERAL THEM WE'RE NOT SPECIFIED
ONE OF THEM WAS MANDATORY.
SO -- WERE
WORKING ON A WEBSITE SO THOSE
WILL BE PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
OTHER BIG THERE WE HELPFUL YEAH
WE HOPE TO HAVE WE HOPE TO HAVE
IT SOON RIGHT IN AND I DON'T
THINK WE NEEDED TO GO DOWN ANY
FURTHER OKAY YES IT'S OF TIME
BUT I DID.
IT WELL WHY THESE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS CAME TO MIND --
WAS RECENTLY LOOKING AT P.
GENIES WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLAN.
AND AS AN AS PART OF THAT PLAN --
THEY STATED THEY WERE CONDUCTING
A THOROUGH SYSTEM WIDE INTENSIVE
INVESTIGATION OF EVERY
TRANSMISSION LINE WALKING THE
THE LINES CLIMBING TOWERS.
IN THE PLAN WAS WAS GOING TO BE
FINISHED BY ME USE OF DRUGS YES
USE OF DRONES IN THAT THE PLAN
WOULD BE --
FINISHED --
WITH THESE INSPECTIONS BY MAY I
THINK IS THE TIMELINE THAT THEY
GAVE BUT AS PART OF THESE
THOROUGH INSPECTIONS.
I WAS JUST WONDERING YOU KNOW
HOW.
DO THEY TRACK WITH THEY FIND IF
THEY FIND REPORTED BACK TO THE
COMMISSION AND HAVE THEY DONE
THAT IS THEY'VE GONE THROUGH.
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THEY HAVE --
I BELIEVE THAT --
OUT OF THE THE THE FORTY
THOUSAND TOWERS IN PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT THEY'VE INSPECTED AND
AND THAT THOUSAND YOU KNOW
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF MILES.
THEY FOUND SOMETHING LIKE FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY VIOLATIONS OF
THE RULES.
THEY HAVE REPORTED THAT FIFTY
NINE OF THEM ARE SERIOUS THEY'VE
CORRECTED ALL OF THOSE SERIOUS
VIOLATIONS.
THAT ACCURATE IS CORRECT IN THE
SENATE AND ACID IN A TIMELY
MANNER SO OUR ENGINEERS CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THEM AS WELL AS
SOON ARE COMING IN YOU'RE YOU'RE
EVALUATING THEM AND AND LOOK AT
THEM AND GUESTS FOLLOWING UP ON
THEM AND IN SOME CASES --
IN TWO CASES OF ACTUALLY GOING
OUT TO THE SIDES AND LOOKING FOR
OURSELVES OKAY THAT'S VERY GOOD
THIS THAT'S GOOD TO HEAR AN
ENCOURAGING AND SENATOR THE
WEBSITE'S UP SO WE WILL SEND YOU
THAT LINK GREAT.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT THE
SECOND ONE IS OF KIND OF LOOKING
AT THAT SAME CULTURE THAT --
SENATOR RUBIO WAS MENTIONED YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE NORTH STAR.
REPORT FROM --
IT IT'S INTERESTING AS LAST YEAR
WHEN THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE MADE THE COMMENTS ABOUT
THE CULTURE P. JEANNIE STATING
THAT IT'S THEIR SAFETY CULTURES
LIKE CHECK IN THE BOX IN.
WHICH IS REALLY UNFORTUNATE AND
THE OTHER PART WAS I THINGS LIKE
WINDOW DRESSING AND I THINK HOW
HE WAS DESCRIBED.
BUT IT IN THE PHASE --
ONE THE THE RECOMMENDATION.
WERE.
SOME OF THOSE WERE FOR THE
COMMISSION NOT JUST PGN.
EIGHT BECAUSE OF THE PHASE ONE
DECISION WAS CONSPICUOUSLY
ABSENT.
WITH ANY COMMENT ON CHANGES THE
COMMISSION MIGHT BE GOING
THROUGH TO SELF IMPLEMENT SOME
OF THESE CHANGES SO HOW'S THE
COMMISSION IMPLEMENTED OR LOOK
AT SOME OF THESE RECOMMENDATIONS.
WHICH ARE APPLIED TO THE
COMMISSION.
I CAN I CAN PROBABLY SPEAK A
LITTLE MORE CLEARLY TO THE THE
EARLIER YOU KNOW INDEPENDENT
REVIEW COMMISSION AND SO WE HAVE
MADE STRONG EFFORTS TO REALLY
TRY TO BUILD A STRONGER SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION.
AND I THINK WE'VE MADE PROGRESS
I THINK THAT THAT WE STILL ARE
UP AGAINST THAT NATURAL
LIMITATION DO WE HAVE THIS RATE
MAKING AGENCY.
THAT THAT DEPENDS ON AUDIT. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I THINK WITH
THAT WAS RECOMMENDED THERE AND I
BELIEVE MY IS IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS RECOMMENDED BY A NOR STAR.
IS THAT WE DEVELOP A A TRUE
ENFORCEMENT ON A REGULAR BASIS
WITH COMMISSIONER REX OFTEN AND
OUR GENERAL COUNSEL AND A COUPLE
OF REPRESENTATIVES OF THE THE
DIVISIONS AND AND SAFE WITH A
FORSMAN DIVISION.
THE INDUSTRY DIVISIONS TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING TO TAKE
TO ACTUALLY GET A TRUE GRADUATED
ENFORCEMENT --
PROGRAM WHERE YOU GET IT YOU
REPORT OF VIOLATION OR WE FIND A
VIOLATION.
THEN YOU GET NOTICED THERE WERE
TRACKING AFTER A CERTAIN PERIOD
OF TIME IF YOU HAVEN'T CORRECTED
IT OR AND YOU CAN'T REPORT TO
ACHIEVE SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
GET A CITATION.
YOU DON'T IF YOU DON'T SATISFY
THROUGH A CITATION NO WAY
<c.blue>SCALATED TO A HIGHER LEVEL OF</c>
ENFORCEMENT THAT'S WHAT YOU
WOULD EXPECT TO SEE AN
UNFORTUNATE POLICY.
WE DON'T HAVE.
CITATION AUTHORITY IN A VARIETY
OF AREAS I JUST SAW A FILING
FROM THE LARGE ENERGY USERS
COALITION SAYING THAT.
THEY DIDN'T THINK THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO COMPLY BECAUSE WE
DIDN'T HAVE CITATION AUTHORITIES
THAT'S NEWS TO ME TO HAVE IT IN
A COUPLE OF AREAS OF ME TO HAVE
THE GAP.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO REALLY
PERFECT THAT BECAUSE WE WANT
PEOPLE TO REALLY TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY AND THERE'S A VARIETY
OF AREAS WERE BECOMES A PROBLEM.
I THINK ONE AREA IS IN THE AREA
OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS WHERE THE
ENFORCEMENT OF VIOLATIONS OF
TELECOMMUNICATION EQUIPMENT ON
YOUTH.
WOULDN'T TOLD PEOPLE USUALLY HAS
TO TAKE PLACE THROUGH THE
UTILITY ON A CIVIL ISSUE BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY TO TOUCH --
VOIP.
TECHNOLOGY SO.
WE HAVE A WAYS TO GO THE
QUESTION WILL BE COMING UP AGAIN
THIS YEAR ABOUT YOUR AUTHORITY
OVER THE P. OVER THOSE ISSUES.
MY LAST QUESTION MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU.
WE WISH THEM A LOT OF TIMES YOU
KNOW DISCUSSING VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT RULES BOTH IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND AND AS A STATE.
AND YOU WORK IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WRAPPING UP THE
FIRE MAP PROCEEDINGS IN
EXTENDING THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT CLEARANCES.
UNDER THAT RULE MAKING HOWEVER I
DIDN'T THE TIME WENT IN LOOKING
AT THAT THAT THERE WAS AN
ENORMOUS EXCEPTION IN GENERAL
RULE.
NINETY FIVE NOT SAID EXCEPTIONS
THAT HAD BEEN ESTABLISHED
DECADES AGO.
AND WHERE WERE THEY IT WSN'T
UPDATED AT ALL DURING THE THE
CLEARANCE CHANGES AND AND IF I
COULD READ THE EXCEPTION FOR TO
RULE.
THIRTY FIVE NGO NINETY FIVE IT'S
VOTE.
THIS IS A MATURE TREES WHOSE
TRUNKS AND MAJOR LIMBS ARE
LOCATED MORE THAN SIX INCHES BUT
LESS THAN THE CLEARANCE REQUIRED.
BY TABLE ONE FROM THE PRIMARY
DISTRIBUTION CONDUCTORS ARE
EXEMPT FROM THE MINIMUM
CLEARANCE REQUIREMENTS UNDER
THIS RULE THAT BASICALLY SAYS
YOU CAN HAVE A SIX INCH
CLEARANCE.
ON SOME.
BRANCHES AND LIMBS NOT THE FOUR
FEET THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED OR
WHATEVER THE THE FOOTAGE WOULD
BE IN THAT --
THE TRUNK AND LIMBS TO TO WHICH
THE EXEMPTION APPLIES SHOW ONLY
BE THOSE OF SUFFICIENT STRENGTH
AND RIGIDITY[inaudible] TO
PREVENT.
THE TRUNK OR LIMB FROM
ENCROACHING UPON THE SIX INCH
MINIMUM CLEARANCE UNDER
REGIONALLY FORESEEABLE LOCAL
WIND AND WEATHER CONDITIONS.
IT SEEMS TO PREVENT VEGETATION
WITHIN SIX INCHES OF A UTILITY
LINES SO LONG AS IT'S OF
SUFFICIENT STRENGTH AND AND I
GUESS IT.
I AM I INTERPRETING THE
CORRECTLY.
HI YES IF YOU ARE INTERNET
CORRECTLY AND IT IN WASN'T
OVERSIGHT AND THAT'S SOMETHING I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WERE IN COMMUNICATION WITH CAL
FIRE AT THIS TIME AND ADDRESSING
THAT COLLABORATIVELY BECAUSE
SOMETHING WE DIDN'T HAVE WAS THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT EXPERTISE.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HOW
FAR DOES HALF AS WE GO TO THE
SITE SO WE SEE THAT --
FOR QUESTIONING IT OURSELVES AND
TAKING A VERY HARD LOOK AT IT
WITH CALIFORNIA IS THAT --
IN SO YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
SUFFICIENT STRENGTH AND RIGIDITY --
ANSWER THE EXCEPTION IS STILL
APPLICABLES MY CONCERN IS WITH
THE FIRES THAT WE'VE HAD IS THAT.
ALMOST THE WITH A GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD BUT IT IS AT A
ONE REASON WHY THE FEW SEE IS
NOT BEEN TAKING A MORE ACTIVE --
AGGRESSIVE ENFORCEMENT ACTION ON
SOME OF THESE FIRES IT WOULDN'T.
BECAUSE OF THIS EXCEPTION.
I DON'T KNOW IF I'D GO THAT FAR
CENTER BUT I WOULD SAY IS AS
ROBBINS CONVERSATIONS WITH CAL
FIRE.
EMILY DEVELOP A WORKING GROUP
WANTED TO ADDRESS IT QUICKLY --
SO THAT'S IN LINE WITH THE SB --
NINE ONE I ARE AND THE ACTUAL
SIGNING OF THE PLANS THEMSELVES
I WOULD SAY AS WELL MANY OF THE
TOADIES CONCLUDE P. JEANNIE HAVE
INCLUDED IN THEIR PLANS.
I'M STANDARDS THAT EXCEED THAT
STANDARD WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT THE CHANGE CONTROL THIRTY
FIVE OKAY.
THANK YOU I THINK YOU'RE I THINK
THE POINT IS NOTED MMHM AND YOU
KNOW AGAIN I THINK WE REALLY
HAVE TO QUESTION WHETHER THE
BEST PRACTICES THAT WE ADOPTED --
BECAUSE OF NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES STANDARDS SET BY THE
NATIONAL ENERGY REGULATORY --
CORPORATION AND ITS PRECURSORS.
PROBABLY JUST DON'T HOLD UP
ANYMORE.
GOOD POINT VERY GOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
INDULGING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
OF THREE QUESTIONS OF MINE AS
WELL -- ONE
ON FIRE FOR A SECOND SINCE
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE --
IN TERMS OF OTHER MITIGATION AT
RISK MITIGATION TECHNIQUES OUT
THERE I KNOW YOU GUYS HAVE YOUR
TECHNOLOGY SUMMIT COMING UP.
GIVE CONCERNS ABOUT --
LACK OF ACCESS TO IT IN SORT OF
THIS UPCOMING FIRE SEASON THE
ACTUAL SUPPLY OF SOME OF THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES THEIR UTILIZING TO
ACTUALLY GET OUT ON THE LINE IN
ADDITION TO THE LINE HARDENING
IN SOME THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WE KNOW FIRE CAMERAS
HAVE BEEN DEPLOYED PRETTY
SUCCESSFULLY BUT I'VE.
HEARD THERE'S A ACTUAL SHORTAGE
IN THE FIRE CAMERA MARKET AND
THAT SOME OF THE I. O. U.'S.
HAVE STATE BASIS THAT WE BOUGHT
UP AS MUCH AS WE CAN AND THAT'S
ALL WE GOT AND WE'RE WE'RE JUST
WE'RE WHERE WE ARE SO JUST A
BRIEF COMMENT ON ON THAT
[inaudible]
THE FIRE.
I HEARD ABOUT THE FIRE CAMERAS
I'VE BEEN FOCUSED A LITTLE BIT
MORE ON THAT THERE'S A LIABILITY
RISK. TO SOME OF THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES SO ONE OF
THE LARGER OF THE COMPANIES TO
ACTUALLY CONTRACT WITH THE
UTILITIES. TO TAKE DOWN TREES ON
TO MEET THE NEW STANDARDS HIS
ACTUALLY BEEN TOLD INTERNALLY BY
THEIR RISK MANAGERS THAT IF
THERE'S A FIRE.
THEY COULD BE LIABLE.
AND THAT THEY'RE LEAVING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND SO THAT THAT THAT THAT WE
ARE STARTING TO SEE SOME
SHORTAGES IT'S TRUE THAT SOME OF
THE UTILITIES ARE REALLY FRONT
LOADING THEIR EXPENDITURES.
OTHERS ARE BEING A LITTLE MORE
MEASURED IN TRYING TO FOCUS ON
VERY.
SPECIFIC AREAS THAT THEY THINK
ARE HIGH HAZARD.
AND SO YOU KNOW.
I COULDN'T TELL YOU WHAT'S THE
RIGHT APPROACH.
AND I'M BELT AND SUSPENDERS
PERSON BUT IT'S PROBABLY.
IF YOU HAVE GOOD JUDGMENT YOU
CAN PROBABLY GET AWAY WITH ABOUT.
N. P. GINNY NOTED AT THE
WORKSHOP --
THE FIRST WORKSHOP FOR THAT'S
BEEN ON ONE IMPLEMENTATION WITH
ACTUAL PERCENT OF THE WATER
MITIGATION PLANS THEY DID NOT AS
A CONCERN --
IN TERMS OF THE FIRE AND THE
CAMERAS AND THE WEATHER STATIONS
THAT SO THAT NEEDS TO BE
VERIFIED --
BUT THAT WAS NOTED AND AS WELL
AS PRESIDENT PICKER SAID ON THE
ACTUAL CRUISE A GOING TO THIS
VISITATION MANAGEMENT --
IT IT'S REACHED A POINT.
AGAIN REPORTED BY SOME THE
UTILITIES THAT THEY'VE REACHED A
CRITICAL MASS OF THERE'S JUST NO
MORE CREWS TO HIRE --
SHOWED.
FURTHER RISK MITIGATION TOOL AT
LEAST.
FOR AGGRESSIVE USE OF PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF WHICH I
KNOW IS ONE OF THE TOOLS THAT
YOU ALL HAVE BEEN --
PUTTING FORWARD BUT OBVIOUSLY A
LOT OF PUSH BACK FROM THE
COMMUNITIES ON THAT FRONT NO ONE
WANTS THEIR POWER SHUT OFF --
BUT YOU KNOW IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES IS NECESSARY BUT%
WAYS TO MINIMIZE THAT DOWNSIDE
RISK WONDERING HOW YOU GUYS ARE
PRIORITIZING --
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED TO
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE LAST YEAR
ON MICRO GRIDS THERE'S ALSO TALK
ABOUT BETTER BATTERY BACKUP
POWER IT'S SORT OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SAY PUMPING
STATIONS FIRE STATIONS.
SO I KNOW YOU GOTTA WALK AND
CHEW GUM AND FIX A CAR AND RIDE
A BIKE AND DO EVERYTHING ALL AT
THE SAME TIME BUT JUST WONDER
WHERE THAT FALLS ON YOUR
PRIORITY LIST.
IN TERMS OF SORT OF EXPEDITED.
THE ACQUISITION YOU KNOW IT
ESPECIALLY IN A HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES FOR THE FOR THAT
KIND OF TECHNOLOGY --
OF THE LET IT ED RANDOLPH ANSWER
THIS YOU DID THAT VERY WELL IN
THE ASSEMBLY SO I GUESS SO WELL
I MEAN I'M JUST YET NARROWLY ON
TO THAT QUESTION ABOUT THE
PRIVATIZATION OF THE MICRO GRADE
BILL --
THERE IS A CHANGE PROPOSAL
PENDING FROM THE LEGISLATURE ON
FOR SEVERAL STAFF --
POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT THAT THE
ANSWER NORMALLY WE WOULD --
LARGELY WAIT UNTIL THE STAFF IN
PLACE TO DO THAT HOWEVER GIVEN
THE PRIORITY THAT WE HAVE
JUGGLED SOME STAFF AROUND.
ON TO START DOING THE WORK ON
THAT BILL ON WELL AHEAD OF TIME
ANTICIPATING.
THAT AS THE COMMISSION DEVELOPS --
MORE PROTOCOLS AROUND SHUT OFFS
ON THAT ISSUES LIKE MICROGRAMS
AND BEHIND THE METER STORAGE
CAUSE FOR SIGNIFICANT CONCERN
AND I WOULD JUST SAY I WOULD ASK --
THE THE PRECEDING THAT'S UNDER
WAY -- UNDER
SB THREE EIGHTY TO ASSESS THE
FEASIBILITY A CLOSURE WHICH THIS
GOVERNOR ALREADY COMMITTED TO
DURING HIS CAMPAIGN BUT THAT.
THE THAT THAT ASSESSMENT SEEMS
TO BE BASED ON ASSUMPTION OF
BUSINESS AS USUAL UNDER UNDER
PREVIOUS LAW IN OTHER WORDS.
THERE'S NO ANTICIPATION OF THE
W. P. --
SHUDDERING.
EVENTUALLY CLOSING DOWN THEIR
GAS PLANTS THERE'S NO ASSUMPTION
OF SB ONE HUNDRED PASSING
THERE'S NO ASSUMPTION OF A HUGE
MARKET PENETRATION UNDER SB
FORTY SEVEN SEVEN AND ELECTRIC
HEAT PUMPS AND OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES SO.
ARE HAVE WE SORT OF ALREADY
RIGGED THAT PROCEEDING TO COME
TO A CONCLUSION OR IS IT ALREADY
IS A P. C. STILL OPEN MINDED
ABOUT.
THE FUTURE OF SORT OF TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATIONS ABILITY TO TO MEET
SOME OF THE GAPS BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT EVEN ASSUMING ANDREA
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN OR THREE
EIGHTY I'M SAYING THE THREE
EIGHTY PROCEEDING LOOKING THE
FEASIBILITY OF CLOSURE DOESN'T
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT NEW ADVANCES
IN BATTERY TECHNOLOGY.
NEW ADVANCE AN ELECTRIC HEAT
PUMPS AS WELL AS SB ONE HUNDRED
AND AND GAS --
PLANT CLOSURE I'M VERY
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT BOY THOSE
BECAUSE WE DON'T CONTROL THE
BUILDING STANDARDS AND I WE HAD
THIS CONVERSATION RIGHT AND THE
IN A I'M FROM VERY OPTIMISTIC I
JUST DON'T SEE THE WILLINGNESS
THERE TO ACTUALLY DEPLOY IT.
SO AGAIN BELTS AND SUSPENDERS.
RIGHT BUT I'M ASKING ABOUT THE
UNDERLYING ASSUMPTIONS OF THE SB
THREE PRECEDING.
IN IN IN I. UNDER MY RELATING
ASSUMPTION FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN IS LA COUNTY WILL PERFORM.
SOME ESTIMATE THREE I DON'T I'M
NOT I'M NOT I'M NOT I'M NOT THE
COULD ASSIGN COMMISSION ON THAT
ANY ANSWER THAT BUT I WILL SAY
I'M VERY FEARFUL THAT IF WE
BUILD THOSE EXEMPTIONS AND BASED
ON WHAT I'M SEEING AROUND THEIR
RESPONSE AND FOR ONLY.
SEVENTY SEVEN AGREED AND YOU CAN
WILL DO ANY SIX THOUSAND NEW
UNITS AND ON YOUR GAS IF YOU
ACTUALLY WANT ELECT I AM SO.
IT SENATOR ON THE THREE EIGHTY
PROCEEDING WHICH BECAUSE OF
THAT'S A COMMISSIONER RANDOLPH'S
PROCEEDING AND BECAUSE OF BAGLEY
KEENE ROLES HARD FOR IT
COMMISSIONERS TO TALK TO EACH
OTHER KIND OF IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE PRECEDING DETAILS.
ON HI I THINK YOU'RE CORRECT IN
WHAT SOME OF THE ASSUMPTIONS ARE
IN THE INITIAL ROUND OF MODELING --
BUT WE'VE HAD A HARD TIME
COMMUNICATING WHAT WE INTEND IS
THE NEXT STEP.
I'M IN THE FIRST ROUND OF THE
MODELING IS TO FULLY UNDERSTAND
HOW THE SYSTEM WORKS --
NOW IN WATER THE CONSTRAINTS
THERE ON THE NEXT ROUND IS THEN
WHERE YOU CAN GO IN AND SAY OKAY
WHAT HAPPENS IF WE OUT A WHOLE
LOT OF CONSERVATION --
WHAT HAPPENS WE DRAMATICALLY GAS
DEMAND AT THE PEAK PERIODS WHAT
HAPPENS IF --
YOU CLOSE DOWN THE FIELD AND
INSTEAD INSTALL MUCH MORE
PIPELINE CAPACITY BOTH SO YOU
CAN GET MORE IN THE STATE IN A
LOT OF REGIONS OF THE COUNTRY
USE PIPELINES AS A STORAGE MEDIA.
I'M SO THAT'S JUST NOT THIS
ROUND -- YOU
KNOW IT'S ANOTHER ONE THESE
PLACES WHERE WE DON'T HAVE A
GREAT STORY TO TELL ON OUR
TIMING --
OTHER THAN THIS IS THIS TYPE OF
MODELING ON THE GAS SYSTEM IS
NOT SOMETHING WE HAVE EXPERTISE
ON AND I THINK IT IS AS YOU'RE
AWARE --
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY THAT HAVE EXPERTISE ON
IT OTHER THAN THE UTILITY SO WE
REALLY STRUGGLED IN THE EARLY
YEARS OF THIS ON HOW TO DO SOME
OF THIS MODELING.
ON IN A WAY THAT THECOMMUNITY
HAD CONFIDENCE.
THAT.
IT WAS GOING TO BE IT WASN'T
GOING TO BE A BIASED MODEL
BECAUSE SO CAL GAS.
IS THE ONE WHO OWNS THE MODELING
SOFTWARE I THINK WE'VE WORKED
OUT NOW --
BUT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONTRACTING PROBLEMS --
IN WORKING WITH --
SOME GOOD NEWS ONLINE TO THIRTY
FIVE IS THE MOST RECENT
INFORMATION I HAVE NOW IS AFTER --
FIFTEEN FORSMAN DIVISION AND
COMMISSIONER RAND OFF.
PUT CONTINUED PRESSURE ON THEM
WERE FAIRLY CONFIDENT THAT THOSE
REPAIRS WILL BE DONE --
WELL BEFORE THIS SUMMER SO IT
THE H. TWO THIRTY FIVE ITSELF
SHOULDN'T HAVE IMPACTS ON THIS
SUMMER THERE ARE OTHER PROBLEMS
IN THE SYSTEM STILL BUT TO
THIRTY FIVE WILL SHOULD BE
RESOLVED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
MISTER BAKER FOR YOUR REPORT
IT'S VERY BIG.
VERY DETAILED AND SO CAN I ASK.
OKAY WELL LET ME AS THERE ARE
SOME QUESTIONS ON SOME SPECIFIC
PAGES --
PAGE.
SIXTY TWO UNDER UTILITY SAFETY --
THERE IS UNDER GROUNDING WITH
THE THE CPUC INITIATED. TO
EVALUATE RULE TWENTY A AND I'M
JUST. TO GET UP TO SPEED ON RULE
TWENTY EIGHT BECAUSE I HAVE.
IT IS MY DISTRICT THAT WOULD
LOVE TO UNDERGROUND AND FEEL
LIKE THEY SHOULD HAVE ACCESS. TO
THAT FUNDING SO MAYBE YOU CAN
KIND OF GIVE ME SO CITIES IN
YOUR DISTRICT PROBABLY DO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE FUNDING BUT THIS
IS A BEAUTIFICATION FUND.
THIS IS NOT A SAFETY FUND THIS
WAS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
BEAUTIFICATION OF DOWNTOWN'S BY
ALLOWING --
TO UNDER GROUNDING THERE.
BECAUSE OF THE DENSITIES.
SO YOU'RE SERVING A LOT OF
CUSTOMERS SO THE WAY THAT IT
WORKS IS THAT EVERY YEAR.
COMMUNITIES GET A CREDIT.
AND YOU CAN ACCUMULATE THE
CREDITS UNTIL YOU GET TO THE
POINT WHERE YOU CAN PAY FOR YOUR
SHARE.
OF THE UNDER GROUNDING IS A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THEN YOU CAT
YOU'VE PUT YOUR MONEY UP YOU
CASH IN THE CREDITS IN UTILITY
WILL WORK WITH YOU TO ACTUALLY
DO THE UNDER GROUNDING.
IT'S A CHALLENGES WELL FOR THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DO THIS
BECAUSE HE CAN'T JUST DO. FOR
BEAUTIFICATION.
THE ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE THEY
HAVE TO GET THE TELCOS TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
AUTHORITY OVER THEM AND NOR
THERE DO WE IN THE SAME WAY WE
HAVE AUTHORITY OVER THE THEIR
TELCO SO.
SOME PEOPLE WILL ACCUMULATE
THEIR CREDITS AND THEY'LL
ACTUALLY SALAM TO OTHER CITIES
SO THAT THEY CAN ACTUALLY A MASS
THE CREDITS MORE QUICKLY TO DO
THEIR PROJECTS.
BUT GENERALLY THESE ARE TO THE
LAW WAS PASSED FOR
BEAUTIFICATION PURPOSES.
AND IT TENDS TO WORK BEST IN
PLACES WHERE YOU HAVE REAL DENSE
POPULATIONS LIKE DOWNTOWN
CENTRAL BUSINESS DISTRICT.
SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IS WHAT WITH THE PROGRAM LOOK
LIKE IF IT WAS ACTUALLY MORE
AIMED AT SAFETY.
THEN HOW CAN I HELP YOU DO THAT.
AT ONE TWENTY BEASON SEES ACT GO
ON THE WERE EACH TRYING TO GET
TO SO I THINK I I THINK I WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE YOU MORE THOUGHTFUL
ANSWER THAT I CAN GIVE YOU HERE --
I THERE ARE THERE ARE SOME OTHER --
AREAS IF WE EXPLORE WITH YOU AND
YOUR STAFF WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
MOVE MORE QUICKLY ON BUT THE
COSTS ARE GOING TO BE VERY HIGH.
AND SO ON THE QUESTION WILL BE
SHOULD THEY BE SOCIALIZED
THROUGHOUT THE RATE BASE.
SO SHOULD YOU OF ON A THE LOW
INCOME COMMITTEES PAY FOR HIGHER
INCOME COMMUNITIES HOW WILL WE
ACTUALLY MAKE SURE THAT THIS IS
FAIR CROSS THE THE ENTIRE
LANDSCAPE OF A PARTICULAR
UTILITY.
SO I JUST I JUST WANT TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU THAT THERE ARE A
LOT OF ISSUES THAT ARE COMING UP
MORE AND MORE AND MORE THAT WE
DID USED TO HEAR ABOUT.
BUT I WANNA I WANNA ACTUALLY
GIVE YOU MORE THOUGHTFUL ANSWERS
AND IT WOULD GIVE YOU HERE.
YEAH I I MET WITH THE ANAHEIM.
UTILITY WHICH IS A CITY UTILITY
FOR ELECTRICITY AND FOR THE LAST
TWENTY YEARS I'VE BEEN
METHODICALLY.
UNDER GROUNDING IN THEIR WILD
FIRES AND SO THEY'VE GOT ABOUT
98% OF THEIR WILD FIRES ON
TAKING CARE OF ANY ARE DOING
BEAUTIFICATION INSIDE.
YOU KNOW THE CITY.
CELLS HAVE JUST I'M LOOKING AT
THIS IS AS A SAFETY OPPORTUNITY.
SO THANK YOU.
LOOK FORWARD TO MORE DISCUSSION
ON PAGE --
TWELVE YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON
SELECT TREES OF THE LECTURE
UTILITY DISTRIBUTION POLLS
REPRESENT BOTH OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHALLENGES.
IN THE PHOTO YOU HAVE THEIR
HUNDRED PAGES SORT OF LIKE.
WHAT I HAVE IN LAGUNA CANYON
ROAD?
WERE FIFTY NINE OF THESE POLLS
HAVE BEEN HIT BY CARS IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS AND KNOCKED OVER
BECAUSE THERE WOULD NAY SNAPPING.
MANY BLOCKED ONE OF THE THREE
ENTRIES INTO.
THE CITY FOR LIKE ALL DAY.
TRY TO BE PATIENT WITH YOUR
DRIVER'S YEAH I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S COYOTES CUT THEM OFF FOR
DEER OR TEXTING ARE YOU KNOW DO
YOU I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS BUT
BUT WHEN THOSE POLLS ARE THAT
CLOSE TO THE ROAD AND YOU'RE
SWERVING OR WHATEVER HAPPENS YOU
FALSELY --
IT'S JUST BEEN A REAL MESS BUT I
WAS I WAS HAVING TROUBLE TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT.
WHAT THOSE TWO PARAGRAPHS FOR
TRYING TO COMMUNICATE?
WELL SO AS WE LOOK AT THE THE
VAST LANDSCAPE OF POLLS THEY
PRESENT AN ENORMOUS CUSTOMER
VALUE THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE REALLY
LIKE TO THINK ABOUT.
BUT THE KERRY AT THE TOP AND YOU
CAN SEE THAT AND IN THIS PICTURE --
THE THE THREE PHASE ALTERNATING
CURRENT.
DOWN BELOW YOU CAN SEE ONE TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDER.
THAT IS THE THAT IS WHAT DRIVES
THE COMPETITIVE ENVIRONMENT AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS IS THEIR
ABILITY TO FIND ACCESS TO THIS
NETWORK OF POLLS A CONNECTS
EVERY HOME EVERY BUSINESS EVERY
COMMUNITY.
AND SO --
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY TWO OF VALUE
POLLS WELL HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
START -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY'S
PAYING THEIR FAIR SHARE FOR
ACCESS TO THIS NETWORK HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY USE THAT TO ACTUALLY
IMPROVE THE OVERALL SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY --
HERE EVERYBODY SAVE MONEY
BECAUSE HE PUT IT CLOSE TO THE
ROAD WITH THEIR EQUIPMENT COULD
BE NOW THE ROAD PROBABLY GREW IN
SIZE FROM MAYBE A DIRT TRACK TO
A PAVED HIGHWAY AND THEN --
TO PAVED ROAD TWO LANE ROAD AND
THEN A PAVED WITH THE WITH THE
LITTLE BIT OF A A MARGIN SO.
THE YOU KNOW THIS IS A CHALLENGE
EVEN FOR A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
THEIR PARTICIPATION TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT THE VALUE OF THAT
NETWORK HOW DO WE TURN THAT INTO
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM.
THIS IS GOING TO BECOME MORE
COMPETITIVE IN THIS IS THIS IS A
DIET STRESS THIS FOR PEOPLE AS
WE MOVE TOWARDS FIVE G..
EVERYBODY WANTS MORE ROBUST.
MOBILE BROADBAND THAT'S FIVE G.
AS A BROADCAST TECHNOLOGY WHAT
IS IT NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
BROADCAST.
THE NEEDS ACCESS TO ELECTRICITY.
IT NEEDS ACCESS TO FIBER IN
NEEDS TO BE ABOUT EVERY THREE
HUNDRED FEET.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE IN THE AIR.
SO WE UNDERGROUND ALL THIS THERE
MAY BE A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
PUSHING THEIR AUTONOMOUS
VEHICLES BECAUSE IS NOT GETTING
DIRECTION.
SO I THAT'S THE CHALLENGE THAT'S
THE OPPORTUNITY.
AND SO WOULD POLLS ARE STILL.
YOU KNOW NOBODY SEEMS TO WANT TO
OWN ONE THERE'S NOT A
COMPETITIVE MARKET PLACE AND IT
IS THE NATURAL MONOPOLY.
BUT HE BRINGS VALUE TO PEOPLE.
THEN ON A PAGE ELEVEN THE CHAIRS
ARE READY.
KIND OF HAMMER ON THIS A LITTLE
BIT AND THAT'S ON YOUR RATE
CASES AND SO.
YOU KNOW THE SENATOR I GET TO
HEAR STORIES OF THREE YEARS FOUR
YEARS FIVE YEARS --
WE'RE STARTING OUR NEXT RATE
INCREASE REQUEST AND WE HAVEN'T
FINISHED THE OLD ONE AND I'M.
A GUY YOU KNOW I'M NEW TO THIS
COMMITTEE SO I'M ASKING KIND OF
BASIC QUESTIONS BUT WHAT WHAT
WOULD BE THE REASON.
FOR SO USE BE PRETTY SIMPLE THE
UTILITIES BASICALLY ARE ARE
EITHER BY OUR LIKELY PHONE
COMPANIES AND ALL BECAUSE YOU
LOOK AT SUCH A BROAD
JURISDICTION ALL OF THEM HAVE
BECOME MUCH MORE COMPLICATED
OVER TIME BECAUSE THE THE
SENSUAL NATURE OF OF WHAT THEY
DO SO FOR EXAMPLE.
THE WATER COMPANIES.
NOW ALSO HAVE TO DEAL WITH I
HAVE TO DEAL WITH --
MORE DEPENDENCE ON GROUND WATER
IN SOME PLACES WERE BUYING WATER
IAN COMMERCIAL MARKETS AND SO
THEY BECOME MORE COMPLICATED
ENTITIES IT TAKES MORE TIME TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE THE
MONEY THEY REALLY NEED IS.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT'S
JUST THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THEY NEED.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ON SHARING THE COSTS
EQUALLY WITH DIFFERENT CLASSES
OF CUSTOMERS.
YOU HAVE WATER COMPANIES THAT
ACTUALLY HAVE BECOME NOT JUST A
LOCAL WATER COMPANY BUT THEY OWN.
DISK CONTIGUOUS.
WATER COMPANIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT THE
PROVIDE YOU UNIFIED RATE CASE.
SO THEWORLD'S BECOME MUCH MORE
CLUTTERING IN AND DIFFICULT
FORCE EVEN THERE.
I THINK THERE ARE OTHER PLACES
WORRY WE JUST NEED TO REALLY GET
BAD RIGHT AND SO FOR EXAMPLE THE
SMALL REGULATED --
OF PHONE COMPANIES.
CAN YOU STILL TAKE A LONG TIME.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO HAVE THE
SAME DEGREE OF OF OF ON
PROCEDURAL ATTENTION.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A JUDGE YOU
HAVE TO HAVE HEARINGS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE A PARTY SUBMITTED YOU
HAVE TO HAVE.
EVIDENTIARY HEARINGS ON THEIR
BOOKS AND IF THEY HAVE OF
SETTLEMENTS IN CASE THERE'S
DISAGREEMENTS FOR YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A FINAL DECISION.
IT GOES OUT FOR COMMENT SO SOME
OF IT IS GOING TO TAKE THE TIME
IT TAKES NO MATTER WHAT.
OTHER PLACES IS JUST BECOME
PHENOMENALLY MORE COMPLICATED
I'LL SAY THAT THE NUMBER OF
CASES THAT WE DEAL WITH THE TO
SEE YOU SEE HAS GROWN OVER TIME.
SO -- IN A
IN A WORLD WE MIGHT HAVE HAD A
HUNDRED CASES WE NOW HAVE OVER
FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR.
WE ONLY HAVE FORTY JUDGES SO
THAT PEOPLE CAN BECOME A
BOTTLENECK.
IS THERE A WAY TO STREAMLINE IT
LIKE -- OF
LIKE AN INFLATION FACTOR.
SO WHAT DOES THAT WOULD THAT
WOULD BE ACCURATE FOR YEARS AND
SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
FOR I MEAN HOW DOES I GET
REIMBURSED FOR THE FOR THE THE
FOUR YEARS IS REALLY THE BIG
COMPANIES THE REALLY BIG ENERGY
UTILITIES IS USUALLY NOT THE
SMALLER ONES --
AGAIN I I YOU KNOW I THINK WE
CAN TRIAL THOSE THINGS BUT IT
DOES OPEN SELF UP.
TO GAMING IN SOME CASES IT
DOESN'T PROVIDE THE TRANSPARENCY
THAT A LOT OF THE PUBLIC WANTS.
THE AMOUNT OF ANGST AND
ATTENTION THAT WE GET FROM
CUSTOMERS OF SMALL WATER
COMPANIES.
IS JUST AS BIG AS SOME OF THE
LARGE ELECTRIC UTILITIES.
AND SO INTO IF YOU WANT TO
PRESERVE THAT DEMOCRATIC
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
CHALLENGE THESE MONOPOLIES.
WE HAVE TO ALLOW THEM TIME TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND THINGS AND TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. FOUR YOU
COULD JUST GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE EVERYTHING.
WHEN A DEMOCRAT EITHER?
WELL I I RESERVE OR MAYES MISTER
PICKER WITH THE WITH THE WHITE
THAN BREATH OF EVERYTHING THAT
THE CPUC DOES THIS WAS VERY
EDUCATIONAL I APPRECIATED.
I A DO YOU HAVE AN ORG CHART ON
YOUR WAY.
ALSO SEND YOU ONE OF THE BIG
GREATER.
I WOULD LOVE AN ORCHARD IS A
AFTER GOING THROUGH THIS.
I WAS I WAS WONDERING.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE JUST TOO BIG
I MEAN IF YOU COULD FOCUS JUST
ON A NARROWER.
AREA YOU CAN GET THINGS VERY
DONE A LITTLE FASTER.
WE CAN DROP IT UP INTO WE'VE
SUGGESTED THAT IN THE PAST AND
WE WE TEND TO RUN UP AGAINST --
CONSTITUTIONAL DEFINITION SUTTER
CHALLENGES WAS STATUTORY
DEFINITIONS SO THERE'S IF YOU
WANT TO TAKE ANOTHER RUN AT IT I
THINK WE WOULD AGREE THAT A
LEANER ORGANIZATIONS SMALLER.
SCOPE OF WHAT WE DEAL WITH MIGHT
BE HELPFUL.
RIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR
TIME TAKE MEASURE RIGHT.
THANK YOU --
PRESENT IN YOUR PRISON TATIAN
YOU MENTIONED --
JUNIOR ORDER ONE FIFTY SIX THAT
WAS IMPLEMENTED BY MISS MORE
NUMBER OF YEARS AGO.
AND APPRECIATE THE UPTICK IN
SPENDING BUT OUR DATA SHOWS THAT
MINORITY BUSINESSES ARE NOT
REALLY GROWING IT'S NOT A
GREATER POOL OF MINORITY BILL
WHAT SEEN.
THIS MANY TIMES WHAT WAS A MALE
OWNED BUSINESS NOW IN IT THE
WIFE OF THE DAUGHTERS NAME.
BUT MY REAL QUESTION IS SOME OF
THE STATE PROGRAMS IN MANDATE.
HAVING A DIRECT IMPACT WHETHER
INTENTIONALLY OR NOT.
ON DIVERSE SPENDING [inaudible]
SO.
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES OWNED ALL OF
THE GENERATION.
AND THE LEGISLATURE OF IN IN IN
ABOUT NINETEEN NINETY SIX
RELIEVE THEM OF THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
SO A LOT OF THE PEOPLE WHO BUILD
POWER PLANTS ARE NOT REGULATED
DIRECTLY WE SIMPLY SEE THE
CONTRACT.
AND SO IS YOU START TO SEE MORE
AND MORE DIFFERENT.
BUSINESS MODELS FOR HOW PEOPLE
GET THEIR ELECTRICITY.
THEN SOME OF THAT SPENDING THEN
MIGRATES AWAY FROM THE UTILITIES --
NET ENERGY MADE ROOFING FOR
EXAMPLE THOSE CONTRACTORS.
WHO DO THAT AND THE COMPANIES
WHO PAY THEM ARE NOT SUBJECT? TO
THE VOLUNTARY PROVISIONS OF OF
GEO.
ONE FIFTY SIX GENERAL ORDER ONE
FIFTY SIX SO WE'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
MEETING WITH THEM A NUMBER OF
TIMES TO TRY TO GET THEM TO
PARTICIPATE AND TO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PROGRAM IN
TERMS OF BRINGING PROSPERITY
STOOD A DIFFERENT.
ON A COMMUNITIES.
AND I WOULD SAY THAT THE THE
THAT THEIR WILLINGNESS TO DO
THINGS HIS BAND.
PARTIAL SOMETIMES OF COME FOR
WITH PROJECTS BUT YOU DON'T SEE
THAT AS A STANDARD BUSINESS
PRACTICE.
IN THE WAY THAT THE UTILITIES
HAVE DONE AND I THINK THE
UTILITIES HAVE TRIED HARD. TO
KEEP PACE WITH SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THE YOU DESCRIBE.
YOU KNOW THEY'VE ACTUALLY GONE
FROM ACTUALLY HAVING CONTRACTORS
WHO ARE DIVERSE BUSINESS FIRMS
TO ACTUALLY DEVELOPING PROGRAMS
FOR THOSE FIRMS TO THEMSELVES
HAVE DIVERSE SUBCONTRACTORS.
AND THAT'S A VERY HEALTHY THING
CAUSES X. THE COMPANY GETS
ESTABLISHED IN THEIR COMMUNITY.
THEN THEY ARE GETTING THE HELP
THEY NEED TO LEARN HOW TO FIND
THE RIGHT PEOPLE AND HELP THEM
ALSO UNDERSTAND HOW TO WORK IN A
SUB CURRENT TRACK TO THE UTILITY.
MEANS YOU HAVE TO HAVE A LONGER
PERIOD SOMETIMES BEFORE YOU'RE
GOING TO GET PAID BACK YOU NEED
TO HAVE AN ON A WILLING BANKER
WHO'S WILLING TO UNDERSTAND.
THE YOU WILL GET PAID BUT TIME
LINES ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
THAN IT WOULD BE IF YOU ARE IN
SMALL BUSINESS ONLY SERVING
PEOPLE IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
SO YOU JUST NOT SEEING THAT FOR
THESE NEW PARTIES AND I THINK
THAT THAT THE THAT I CONTINUETO
TO THINK WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WAYS TO INSPIRE THEM TO THE
GREATNESS.
THE THE OTHER OF PROVIDERS HAVE.
ARM WAS STICKING TO THE
UTILITIES AREA THAT THEY DO HAVE
DIRECT.
IMPACT ON RIGHT NOW IN THE AREA
THAT WE BOUGHT TOUCH TOUCH UPON
HIS LINE CLEARING.
THERE'S NOT A SINGLE MINORITY
FIRM BEING USED FOR VEGETATION
CLEARING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEY DO EXIST SEOUL WHY NOT
THERE SHINING A LIGHT THERE THE
ENCOURAGED THAT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE WE WE'VE ALL TALKED
ABOUT THE NEED OF LINE CLEARING
HELP.
ABATE THESE FIRES BUT YOU'RE NOT
USING ANY MINORITY CONTRACTORS
TO DO SUCH OKAY THAT'S GOOD
POINT THANK YOU FOR FOR LETTING
US KNOW WILL FOLLOW UP ON IT.
AND MY SECOND ONE IS --
I MEAN THIRD ISSUE ARCHDIOCESAN
I WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW HAVE MINIMUM
REGULATORY OVERSIGHT OVER CCA'S
THEY'RE NOT HEARING A ONE FIFTY
SIX WE'RE NOT HEARING TO ANY
OTHER THING SO --
IN YOUR PERSPECTIVE DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO GIVE THEM MORE
RESPONSIBILITY BUT LESS
OVERSIGHT.
NO -- IN
I'VE HAD THIS CONVERSATION WITH
THEM SEVERAL TIMES AND AGAIN
THEY THEY WHAT THEY VIEW IS
THEIR JOB IS TO DO.
SMALL EMPLOYMENT.
THEY DON'T EMPLOYEE BY THE NO
THEY DO AROUND THEIR CONTRACTORS
TO BUILD THESE SMALL PROJECTS
THE DOING THEIR DISTRICT.
THEY DON'T DO THAT ON SOME THEIR
LARGER CONTRACTS BUT THEY
THEMSELVES DON'T DON'T HAVE
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS SO USUALLY
IT'S A SMALL.
PROJECT IN ITS CONSTRUCTION WORK
IN AT THE END OF THAT PROJECT
THEN OF COURSE PEOPLE HAVE TO GO
INTO THE CONSTRUCTION WILL.
WHICH IS ALWAYS CYCLICAL TO
BEGIN WITH PARTICULARLY IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES SO I HAVE I
HAVE QUESTIONS AS TO WHETHER
THAT'S REALLY.
AS EFFECTIVE AS THEY THINK IT IS.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY TO
MAKE THEM DO THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE AUTHORITY TO EVEN
REQUIRE THEM TO CONSIDER.
GEO ONE FIFTIES OKAY BUT SHOULD
THEY HAVE BACK TO OVERSIGHT
SHOULDN'T YOU GUYS HAVE GREATER
OVERSIGHT OVER.
A ENTITY AYE AYE LET ME TELL YOU
ONLY REASON I ASK QUESTIONS
BECAUSE I'M OFFER COMPETITION.
BUT I WORK FOR A MAJOR UTILITY
TURN ENERGY CRISIS AND I DON'T
SEECCA'S ANY DIFFERENT FROM
ENRON THEIR THIRD PARK PARTY
REMARKETER OF POWER.
AND WHEN YOU SAY ONE OF THEM GO
CREDIT SHE LINE OF CREDIT --
AND WHO'S RESPONSIBLE YEAR
INCUMBENT UTILITY.
AND IF I STOP BUYING POWER FOR
THAT COM OUR CUSTOMER AND NOW MY
CCA GOES BACK GROW WHAT WE OUT
WE BOUGHT IT WE HAVE UTILITY
BUYING POWER ONCE AGAIN ON THE
SPOT MARKET.
YOU KNOW TO SERVE THAT CUSTOMER.
CHAU I WOULD I'M JUST GONNA
QUICKLY --
POINT TO THESE TWO STUDIES DEAD
ONE WAS THAT SORRY.
RUN REPORT ONE WAS --
WAS -- RUN
REPORT.
BUT HERE IT IS --
SOMEPLACE HERE.
WE DID TWO STUDIES ONE WAS AN
EXAMINATION OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE ELECTRICITY MARKETS HERE
IN CALIFORNIA WHAT HAPPENS IS
THESE THIRD PARTY START TO
PROVIDE MORE ELECTRIC SERVICE TO
CUSTOMERS.
THERE'S TECHNOLOGIES AND THERE'S
BUSINESS MODELS IS DIRECT ACCESS
IS.
THE PACE --
ANA LENDERS IT'S THE IT'S THE
THE THE THE COMPETITIVE
COMMUNITY AGGREGATOR THE NET
ENERGY METERED ROOFTOP SOLAR AND
TO SOME EXTENT THE THE FUEL CELL
THE NATURAL GAS FUEL SO
COMPANIES.
ALL HAVE ALLOWED OF VARIOUS
CUSTOMERS TO DEPART FROM THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES IS WILL PLACE
FOR THE BUY THEIR ELECTRICITY --
I WE LOOKED AT FOR STATE THERE
HAVE ACTUALLY.
THIRD OF GOING DOWN THIS PATH.
AND WHAT BECOMES CLEAR IS WERE
SORT OF BETWEEN.
THE THE VERTICALLY INTEGRATED
UTILITY AND A FULLY DEREGULATED
ELECTRICITY MARKET SO WE'RE KIND
OF ON CHARTED AND POTENTIALLY
DANGEROUS TERRITORY.
YOU POINTED TO SOME OF IT --
THIS IS OUR SECOND REPORT AND
BASED ON WHAT WE LEARNED FROM
THOSE OTHER FOUR STATES IT'S
SUGGESTS A VARIETY OF THINGS
THAT WE SHOULD DO TO ACTUALLY
PROTECT AGAINST SOME OF THE THE
DANGERS AND THE SUN CHARTED
TERRITORY.
WE DID DISCUSS THE THERE'S
RESPONSIBILITY TO USE.
YOUR INVESTMENTS IN YOUR
CONTRACTORS IN A WAY THAT
SUPPORTED ALL OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AS WELL THAT
DIVERSITY CONTRACT THERE'S
PROGRAM SO.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO LOOK AT THAT
I KNOW THAT --
THEY COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS IS
PLANNING ANOTHER HEARING SOLELY
ON THAT SO I DON'T WANT TO SPEND
TOO MUCH TIME ON THAT MY LAST
QUESTION IS IF YOU'RE THE TO CC
AGE TO NOT HAVE TO COMPLY WITH.
PALMER USE RULES THIS IS THE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES I DON'T
STRUCTURE THEY TEND TO THINK
PRIMARILY ABOUT --
CLEAN ENERGY THE CCA IS THE
CLEAN THE COMBATIVE COMMITTEE
AGGREGATORS ORIGINALLY WERE
FORMED TO ACTUALLY GET CHEAPER
PRICES.
BUT THAT'S SORT OF THAT SORT OF
BEEN LOST IN A IN A RACE TO BE
AS GREEN AS YOU CAN BE SO I
THINK THAT THE THE THE THE GAMES
A CHANGE.
I THINK THAT MOST OF THEM WHEN
THEY DO LEARN ABOUT TIME OF USE
OF JUST KIND OF DECIDED THAT
THEY WOULD WHAT THEY WOULD STICK
WITH THE UTILITY.
OF RATES BUT THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY DO THAT WE
COULD FIND SOME OF THEM DECIDE
NOT [inaudible]
TO THANK YOU [inaudible]
I'M.
IF I UNDERSTAND CORRECTLY THE
REFERENCES THAT EARLIER ON WHERE
THE QUESTIONS WERE ASKED AROUND --
MY COLLEAGUE --
SENATE RUBIO REFERENCING THE
NINETEEN PROGRAMS --
IT AROUND THE SAFETY ALL OF
BROADLY SAY SAFETY CULTURE.
THEN WE HAVE THE NORTH STAR --
ART THAT YOU REFERENCE TO REPORT
THE REFERENCE.
SO IS LET ME SEE IF I UNDERSTAND
SCRIPT BY UNDERSTAND CORRECT
WHAT I'VE INTERPRETING IS THAT.
THE PC IS.
WORKING NOW TO TRY TO GET MORE.
MORE.
US A CONSISTENCY AND CLARITY
AROUND.
THESE KIND OF SAFETY RULES SO
THAT THEY CAN BE.
IN FORCED MORE AT SO IT'S EASIER
TO DO THE ENFORCEMENT WE DON'T
TO ENFORCEMENT OVER THEIR SAFETY
PROGRAMS PER SE WHAT WE DO IS
ENFORCE FAILURES. TO ACTUALLY BE
SAFE OKAY SO BUT WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S AN ISSUE HERE AND A THE
ORIGINAL --
INDEPENDENT REVIEW PANEL.
OF EXTERNAL --
OF THIRTIES WHO LOOKED AT ASSN
P. GINNY SUGGESTED THAT WE START
TO LOOK AT THESE ISSUES RIGHT.
THE PLACE WERE REALLY --
PROBABLY SHOWS UP MOST IS AS
WITH WE UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT
ELEMENTS GO INTO THEIR SAFETY
CULTURE.
WE'LL SEE THAT IN THEIR RISK
THAT'S WHERE WE WOULD ACTUALLY
REVIEWED DESIST MAKES SENSE AS
AN EXPENDITURE RIGHT.
AND SO AGAIN IT'S HARD TO KNOW
SOMETIMES YOU WANT TO SEE THINGS
PLAY OUT OVER A COUPLE OF YEARS
TO SEE IF IT ACTUALLY RESULT IN
LESS.
LEADING INDICATORS SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE DENNIS IS PROBABLY
NOT THE BEST ONE BUT WHEN I WAS
ON THE BOARD OF THE SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT.
THEY ACTUALLY COUNT NEAR MISSES
IN THE PARKING LOT.
BECAUSE THAT TELLS THEM WHO IS
REALLY.
DOING ALL THE THINGS THAT THEY
WANT HER PEOPLE WERE DRIVING ONE
OF THEIR EQUIPMENT TRUCKS TO DO.
THAT TELLS THEM THAT PEOPLE ARE
BEING THOUGHTFUL THEY HAVE OTHER
KIND OF LEADING INDICATORS THAT
THEY LOOK AT IN THE FIELD.
SO DID YOU KNOW IT'S JUST SIMPLE
THINGS THAT TELL YOU WHETHER
PEOPLE ARE ACTUALLY PRACTICING
GOOD SAFETY.
THEN YOU MEASURE THE LAGGING
INDICATORS WAS ARE MORE CRAP AND
FAILURE WITH THEIR MORE
COLLISIONS DID YOU HAVE MORE
ACCIDENTS ON THE ROAD.
SO YOU WANT TO HAVE A BALANCE OF
THOSE KINDS OF METRICS TO REALLY
SEE HOW WELL THINGS WORK.
AND EVEN THEN YOU MAY NOT HAVE
THE RIGHT SET OF METRICS TO
REALLY GET ON A DEAL WITH THE
HIGH CONSEQUENCE BUT LOWER
CURRENTS.
KINDS OF INITIATIVES BUT YOU
WANT YOU WANT IF YOU WANT TO
START THERE SO THE EXAMPLE THAT
I USE WHEN I TALK TO PEOPLE
ABOUT ITSELF CO.
WHERE THEY ACTUALLY IMPROVED
THEIR OVERALL PROFITABILITY
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SO FOCUSED ON
SAFETY WITHIN THE AREA?
THAT THEY STARTED TO ACTUALLY
NOTICE THINGS AND REPORTED BACK
UP THE CHAIN.
THERE ENDED UP IN SAVINGS BOTH
IN TERMS OF INSURANCE COSTS AND
LOST TIME BUT ALSO PROCESS
IMPROVEMENT.
AND SO YOU WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THAT KIND OF UNDERSTANDING OF
WHY YOU DO THINGS SO THAT PEOPLE
CAN THEN PICK IT APART AND SEE
WHERE TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS.
SO THE GET EVEN BETTER AND
BETTER SAY AND A RISK MANAGEMENT
STRATEGY OUR CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT CONCEPT RATHER THAN
COMPLIANCE WHICH IS STEADY STATE
TO DO THIS AND THEN YOU SHOULD
BE OKAY.
I DON'T MEAN TO MINIMIZE THE COM.
PLEX CITY OF IT BUT I AM I'M
JUST THINKING SAY ON THE
WILDFIRE PART AND I APPRECIATE
THE CLARIFICATION.
THAT WE DON'T ENFORCE.
THAT YOU DO A TAX OR WHY WE
MOURN FORCE THAT YOU THAT
WHATEVER PROCEDURES YOU'RE USING
THAT YOU HAVE.
MINIMIZE THESE RISKS --
HOWEVER.
AS YOU POINTED OUT SINCE.
SINCE THAT IS SOMETHING THEY
CHARGE TO RATE PAYERS --
AND AND I'M PARTLY THINKING
ABOUT THE JUDGE RIGHT NOW WHO'S
BASICALLY LOOKING AT SB OPINING
THAT P. GENIES --
BOTH ATTENTION TO A DEDICATION
TO AND NOT ONLY THOROUGHNESS BUT
REALLY JUST --
ACTIVITY IN RELATIONSHIP TO
WILDFIRE PREVENTION YOU KNOW
ACCORDING TO THIS JUDGE AT LEAST
IN THE OLD --
PINING THAT I'VE READ IT READ IN
THE PRESS REPORTS YOU KNOW IS IN
HIS OPINION VERY BAD.
AND SO HE'S NOW ORDERING CERTAIN
THINGS WHICH OF COURSE.
WOULD IT SEEMS TO ME HARVARD
THEN END UP BEING THINGS THAT
REPAIRS WOULD HAVE TO BE CHARGED.
TO SO I'M WHAT I'M STARTING WITH
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO GO INTO A
LOT OF DETAIL AT THIS NOW BUT
THAT WITHOUT.
A CLEAR PROTOCOL FOR WHAT IS
ACTUALLY GOING TO HELP INSURE
GOOD.
SAFETY IN RELATIONSHIP TO
WILDFIRE PREVENTION THEN HOW IS
IT THAT WE CAN.
JUSTIFY THEIR EXPENDITURE AND I
REASON AGAIN MAYBE NOT THE BEST
ANALOGY BUT I THINK ABOUT.
WHAT HOSPITALS HAVE PUT INTO
PLACE NOW SAVE WITH SURGERIES OR
WHAT THEY DON'T CARE WHAT THE
SURGERY IS EVERYONE ELSETO
FOLLOW A VERY SIMILAR PROTOCOL?
WHICH HELPS IN WHICH THEY HAVE
TESTED OVER TIME THAT MINIMIZES
MISTAKES IN THE SURGERY
REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
SURGERY AND SO.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE FOR US IS
TO LEARN HOW TO DO THAT WHEN
NONE OF US ACTUALLY OUR WORK ON
LINE CREWS.
NONE OF US ACTUALLY MOVE MANAGE
LYING CRUZ EITHER GAS INSPECTION
OR OR ELECTRIC.
IT THE DOWN TO THOSE BEST
PRACTICE MODELS RATE AND THIS IS
THIS IS NW TO US IS IT IS IN
MANY OTHER PLACES WE STUDIED A
VARIETY OF THE DIFFERENT KINDS
OF MODELS.
AND AGAIN I POINTED TO THE INFO
YOU CAN LOOK AT THE EXAMPLE OF
THE FAA WERE THE THE THE THE
ONLY CRIME AT THE FCA IS FAILURE
TO REPORT.
AN INCIDENT.
THEN THEY ARE ALL EVERYBODY
STOPS TO TO REALLY UNDERSTAND.
AND THAT'S THE WHOLE ARGUMENT
AROUND WHETHER THEY SHOULD
GROUND THE FLEET OF SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN SO --
BUT WILL NORTH STAR.
POTENTIALLY PROVIDE I MEAN NOT
THAT THEY WILL PROVIDE AN ANSWER
BUT MIGHT THEY PROVIDE SOME.
GUIDANCE NINE YEAR SORT OF
ASKING ME IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT TO HER DIRECT WHAT I'M
GONNA HAVE IN MY POCKET OKAY ALL
RIGHT.
HI ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE TO CHANGE WE KNOW
THAT THERE ARE TOOLS OUT THERE
WERE STRUGGLING TO UNDERSTAND
AND APPLY THEM.
WE WANT TO HAVE BEST PRACTICES
BE JUST CAN'T GET HIM OFF THE
SHELF.
SO THE LAST QUESTIONS GIVE
MAKERS COMPLETELY NOT ON THE
FIRE -- YOU
REFERENCE THE AD CARBONIZATION
OF BUILDINGS AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT OTHER KICK OTHER COMMUNITY
SO FOLLOW THE LEAD OF BERKELEY.
OKAY.
BUT I THINK CERTAINLY GIVEN
CALIFORNIA'S YOU KNOW WE'RE APT
WERE OBVIOUSLY ACCELERATING.
OUR EFFORT TO TRY TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND D.
CARBONIZED ECONOMY AND CLEARLY
DE CARBON ICING BUILDINGS IS AN
ASPECT OF IT AND WHAT.
WE'D WANT TO DO IT WISELY OF
COURSE BUT YOU KNOW I LOOK
FORWARD.
TO THANK THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN ALL YOUR ALL THE INFORMATION
TO SHARE WITH US WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ONTO THEIR FOR THE PUBLIC
AT ADVOCATES OFFICE --
ELIZABETH ECKELS [inaudible]
COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE.
I WANT TO FIRST INTRODUCE MY
DEPUTY FOR ENERGY LINDA SERIZAWA
ON MY RIGHT AS WELL AS MY CHIEF
COUNSEL DARWIN FOR OUR AND WE
ALL APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT.
HE ACTIVITIES AND
ACCOMPLISHMENTS FROM TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AS WELL AS SOME OF THE
BIGGER ISSUES THAT THAT ARE
BEFORE US.
TODAY.
OF COURSE WELL ACTUALLY BEFORE I
STARTED IS WHEN A CHECK TO MAKE
SURE AND NO MORE.
CPC DECISION MAKERS ARE IN THE
ROOM.
OKAY BECAUSE OTHERWISE I HAVE TO
READ A STATEMENT FROM OUR
ATTORNEY REGARDING EX PARTE.
BUT IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE THEY'RE
HERE OKAY.
SO -- AS YOU
KNOW THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE IS INDEPENDENT CONSUMER
ADVOCATE AT THE P. YOU SEE AND
OUR MISSION IS TO ACHIEVE THE
LOWEST POSSIBLE RATES FOR
CUSTOMERS CONSISTENT WITH SAFE
AND RELIABLE SERVICE.
OUR GOAL IS TO ACHIEVE THE BEST
VALUE FOR CONSUMERS ACROSS THE
REGULATED INDUSTRY.
ENERGY WATER AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
WE ALSO WORK HARD TO MAKE SURE
THAT NO ONE IS LEFT BEHIND AND
THAT ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS
TO SAFE AFFORDABLE UTILITY
SERVICES.
WE PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL VALUE FOR
CUSTOMERS BY ALSO WORKING TO
IMPROVE THE SAFETY OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WE WORK HARD TO PROVIDE
INPUT ON UTILITY PROGRAMS ACROSS
INDUSTRY AREAS THAT REDUCE THEIR
SAFETY RISKS AND INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY IN THE PROCESS.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING.
HOW IMPORTANT WE BELIEVE IN THIS
CURRENT STATE WITH THE WILD
FIRES AND THE P. JEANNIE
BANKRUPTCY?
HOW OUR TOP PRIORITY IS TO WORK
WITH YOU THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
AND THE PC?
AS WELL AS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
THEIR PROPERTY AND THEIR
ENVIRONMENT ARE SAFE.
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT MY
HEART GOES OUT TO THE VICTIMS OF
THE TRAGIC WILDFIRES THAT OUR
STATE HAS EXPERIENCED.
AND WE ALSO MUST ADDRESS
CUSTOMERS VERY REAL CONCERNS
ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
NEXT [inaudible]
SIMPLY PUT.
ESTAMOS MUST KNOW THAT THE
LIGHTS WILL STAY ON THEIR
UTILITY SYSTEMS MUST BE MADE
SAFE AND RELIABLE AND THAT
CUSTOMERS CAN'T.
FOOT THE BILL FOR ANY POTENTIAL
UTILITY MISDEEDS.
AS DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE I ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE
MUST PUT THE INTERESTS OF
VICTIMS CUSTOMERS AND RANK AND
FILE P. JEANNIE EMPLOYEES FIRST.
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS THAT WE
CAN DO TO HONOR THOSE WHO
SUFFERED AS A RESULT OF THE
FIRES.
IS TO TAKE REAL STEPS TO
MINIMIZE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WILL HAPPEN
AGAIN.
AND AT THE SAME TIME CUSTOMERS
SHOULDN'T.
AND CAN'T CONTINUE TO PAY AND
PAY AND PAY.
THE COMMISSION'S RECENTLY OPENED
PROCEEDING THE END DISCONNECTION
ARE ASKING MANY OF THE SAME
QUESTIONS THAT.
BUT ABOUT CUSTOMERS ABILITY TO
PAY THAT.
ARE GOING TO COME UP IN THE
BANKRUPTCY PROCEEDING.
WITH TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AT STAKE.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT THE CUSTOMER
HAS A VOICE IN THESE PROCEEDINGS.
WE ARE OF COURSE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN THE P. YOU SEE
RELATED PROCEED THE THE P.
JEANNIE RELATED.
PROCEEDINGS AT THE P. C..
AND IN ADDITION WE HAVE JOINED
WITH TURN A AND P. AND OTHERS TO
ASK THE BANKRUPTCY COURT
[inaudible] TO LET US FORM A
RATE PAYERS COMMITTEE AND WE
ALSO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN
ESTABLISHING A REPAIR COMMITTEE
SO THAT THE VOICES OF CONSUMERS
CAN BE HEARD IN THIS PROCESS.
NOW I'LL TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME OF OUR
ACHIEVEMENTS FROM FROM LAST YEAR
I YOU SHOULD ALL HAVE COPIES OF
BOTH OUR ANNUAL REPORT.
AS WELL AS THE THE SLIDES GREAT
SO VERY QUICKLY --
FIRST OF ALL.
LAST YEAR THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE SAVED CONSUMERS OVER
THREE POINT THREE BILLION AND
REDUCED RATES OF WHAT IT COSTS
AND CUSTOMER REFUNDS AT THAT'S
COMPARED WITH WHAT THE UTILITIES
REQUESTED.
THAT PAGE THREE OF THE THE SLIDE
AND WANT TO REFER YOU --
TO OUR DEDICATED TEAM OF
ANALYSTS ENGINEERS AND AUDITOR'S
DID THIS BY.
PARTICIPATING IN LITERALLY
HUNDREDS OF PC PROCEEDINGS
FILING OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
PLEADINGS IN THOSE CASES AND
WORKING WITH MANY STAKEHOLDERS
TO SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATE FOR
CUSTOMERS BEFORE THE CPC AND
OTHER FORMS.
AND I'M ALSO PROUD TO SAY THAT
OVER THE LAST DECADE.
OUR SAVINGS FOR UTILITY
CUSTOMERS IS NOW OVER FORTY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS.
OF COURSE IN ADDITION TO OUR
WORK ON GENERATE CASES AND OTHER
RATE IMPACTING PROCEEDINGS WE
ALSO ADVANCED A POLICIES.
TOWARDS ADVOCATING FOR
AFFORDABLE AND UNIVERSAL
SERVICES FOR UTILITY SERVICES
ENSURING SAFE AND RELIABLE
UTILITY OPERATIONS AND
ADVOCATING FOR THE COST
EFFECTIVE ADVANCEMENT OF THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
A KEY DRIVER OF OUR MISSION IS
ADVOCATING FOR AFFORDABLE
UTILITY SERVICES. FOR EXAMPLE
WERE ACTIVELY PARTICIPATING IN
THE PC'S RULE MAKING THAT'S
FOCUSED ON DEVELOPING A
FRAMEWORK TO MEASURE
AFFORDABILITY ACROSS INDUSTRY
SECTORS.
BUT EVEN BEFORE THIS PROCEEDING
WAS OPENED WE WERE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN BRINGING TO THE PC'S
ATTENTION AND CALLING FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY AROUND ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PIECE MEAL.
RATE INCREASES THAT ARE OUTSIDE
THE GENERAL RATE CASES --
TO MAKE SURE THAT.
THESE ADDITIONAL INCREASE RON
RATES ARE TRANSPARENT AND THAT
THE PC IN CONSIDERING THESE
VARIOUS REQUESTS CAN CAN LOOK AT
THAT THE BROADER PICTURE SO WE
HAVE.
RECOMMENDED TO THE PC THAT
UTILITIES PROVIDE INFORMATION ON
THE CUMULATIVE EFFECT OF RECENT
AND PENDING AND FUTURE INCREASES
ON RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS RATES
AND BILLS.
AND THIS INFORMATION WOULD
ENABLE THE PC TO BETTER
PRIORITIZE UTILITY PROPOSALS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
POLICIES AND MORE TRANSPARENT
MANNER.
OF COURSE ANOTHER IMPORTANT PART
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR MISSION IS
TO ADVOCATE FOR COST EFFECTIVE
SERVICE THAT IS PROVIDED IN A
SAFE.
AND RELIABLE MATTER.
AND HOLDING UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HOW THEY OPERATE
AND MANAGE THEIR FACILITIES IS
PARAMOUNT.
TO ENSURING SAFETY AND
RELIABILITY.
OVER THE LAST DECADE IN
PARTICULARLY SINCE THE TRAGIC
SAN BRUNO NATURAL GAS PIPELINE
EXPLOSION.
WE HAVE BROADENED AND DEEPENED
OUR SAFETY EXPERTISE WITH THE
SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
WE HAVE A PROVEN TRACK RECORD
ADVOCATING FOR STRONGER SAFETY
REGULATIONS AND UTILITY
COMPLIANCE. FOR EXAMPLE LAST
YEAR WE SUCCESSFULLY ADD
ADVOCATED THAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY AND SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC BE REQUIRED
TO PRESSURE TEST AND WHERE
NECESSARY REPLACE PARTS OF ONE
OF THEIR MAJOR NATURAL GAS
TRANSMISSION LINES.
WE PROVIDE A COMPELLING AN
ACCURATE INFORMATION TO SHOW
THAT.
THEY NEEDED TO PRINT PRESSURE
TEST SEIZE FIND CONSISTENT WITH
FEDERAL AND STATE REGULATIONS
AND AND THE PC DID ADOPT THAT.
WE ALSO SUCCESSFULLY ADVOCATED
FOR ENHANCED CUSTOMER
PROTECTIONS ACROSS ENERGY AND
WATER SERVICES THEY WOULD BE IN
PLACE ANY AFTER ANY NATURAL
DISASTER MAKING IT EASIER FOR
LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS IN
PARTICULAR. TO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE DISCOUNTED RATES AS WELL
AS A SPENDING VARIOUS FEES AND
DEPOSIT REQUIREMENTS SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET THEIR SERVICE UP
AND RUNNING.
MORE QUICKLY.
YOU PROCEDURES. TO IMPLEMENT SB
NINE A ONE AND THERE WERE
FOCUSED OUR REVIEW ON THE
UTILITIES COMPLIANCE WITH SB
WHAT NINE A ONE REQUIREMENTS.
OUR THIRD POLICY GOAL OF COURSE
IS TO HELP ADVANCE THE STATE'S
CLIMATE GOALS MOST EFFECTIVELY.
HERE WE SEE.
A CRITICAL. TO CREATE POLICIES
THAT WILL ACHIEVE A 100%
RENEWABLES BUT IN A WAY THAT'S
COST EFFECTIVE SO THAT THESE.
THESE POLICIES CAN ALSO BE
EXPORTABLE TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS THAT MAY NOT BE
WILLING TO PAY QUITE AS MUCH.
SO OF COURSE CALIFORNIA'S ONLY
RESPONSE OF FOR ABOUT 1% OF THE
WORLD'S GHG EMISSIONS.
SO WE MUST ENSURE THAT OUR
PROGRAMS CAN BE READILY
EXPORTABLE.
AN EXAMPLE OF THAT IS THAT WE
ADVOCATED FOR THE UTILITY
TRANSPORTATION LIKED VACATION
PROGRAMS. TO ENABLE INCREASED
DEPLOYMENT OF ELECTRIC.
VEHICLES WHILE MAXIMIZING THE
BENEFITS TO CUSTOMERS AND IN
PARTICULAR WE PRIORITIZE
TRANSPORTATION LIKE VACATION IN
DISADVANTAGE IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
SEC S. TO SEPARATE SITTING
COURAGE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING AT TIMES THAT WOULD
ENHANCE GRIN RELIABILITY.
AND ESTABLISH PERFORMANCE
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT
MAXIMIZE LESSONS LEARNED AND
PUBLIC BENEFIT.
AND SO WHAT THE PC ADOPTED WAS A
BUDGET THEY REDUCE THE UTILITY'S
REQUEST BY TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS BUT STILL
ACHIEVED AT THE TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION.
DEPLOYMENT THAT WAS MORE IS
DESIRED.
SO WITH THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE HAD A LONG DAY
SO I'M GONNA JUST WRAP UP AND
SAY THANKS AGAIN FOR BEING HERE
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU ALL GOING FORWARD.
AND HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MR NICHOLS
[inaudible]
CENTER SKINNER [inaudible]
CENTER HERTZBERG [inaudible] ONE
TWO SENATOR OUT [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
SO OF MS ACOSTA COULD YOU GIVE
US ANOTHER EXAMPLE YOU JUST GAVE
A VERY CONCRETE EXAMPLE.
OF WHERE --
YOUR INTERVENTIONS ARE YOUR
OFFICES INTERVENTIONS --
I HELP TO YOU SEE.
A DOCTOR RULE THAT.
PROVIDED THE DESIRED OUTCOME OF
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
OR INCREASING TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION WITH STILL --
GIVING SOME RATE SAVING SOME
FUNDS FOR REPAIRS AND DIRECTING
POTENTIALLY SOME OF THE ACTIVITY.
TOWARDS RATE PAYERS WHO MIGHT
OTHERWISE NOT --
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM CAN YOU
GIVE ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS CONCRETE
ONE SURE BE HAPPY TO SO ANOTHER
ONE IS IN THE PRECEDING WHERE
WE'RE LOOKING AT HOW TO
INTEGRATE MORE IT DE OURS ON TO
THE GRID --
THERE WE ARE LOOKING BOTH AT
WHERE WHERE CAN THOSE --
IN IT DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES BE --
BEST INTEGRATED WITH THE GRID TO
MAXIMIZE BENEFIT AS WELL AS WHAT
ARE THE WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE --
BEST MIX OF RESOURCES TO TO A
100% BUT THAT WE CAN DO IT IN A
WAY THAT IS MORE COST EFFECTIVE --
AND WE AS PART OF THAT
PROCEEDING WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT
HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
ARE SERVED AND I DON'T KNOW I'VE
GOT THEM COURSE MY DEPUTY FOR
ENERGY HERE SO IF LINDA WANTS TO
ADD ANYTHING [inaudible] TO THAT.
IN THE THE DISTRIBUTION RESOURCE
PLANNING PROCEEDING WHICH IS
WHAT --
ELIZABETH WAS SPEAKING TO A WE
ACTUALLY PROPOSED IT WAS ADOPTED
AND FRAMEWORK FOR IDENTIFYING
WHERE -- A
PROCESSOR FRAME IT FOR DID
IDENTIFY WHERE DISTRIBUTED
ENERGY RESOURCES SHOULD BEST BE
PLACED ON THE SYSTEM TWO AND A
TO ENSURE OUR TO SUPPORT
RELIABILITY AS WELL AS TO
INSURER.
OR SPPORT THE STATE'S BUDGET
SHE REDUCTION GOALS SO THAT WAS
A A MASSIVE PROJECT FRANKLY
CAUGHT TRYING TO COME UP WITH A
FAIR PROCESS.
AS WELL AS A TRANSPARENT PROCESS
BECAUSE AS YOU WELL KNOW OF
THERE ARE A LOT OF NEW PLAYERS
IN THE DISPUTE ENERGY RESOURCE
WORLD -- AND
THEY DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
DEVELOP THE PROJECTS SO WE'RE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE'S
A FAIR.
PLAYING FIELD FOR EVERYBODY AND
THAT WEEK THEY GET THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED AS WELL AS
WE DO.
SENATE SKINNER SENATOR RUBIO.
SINCE HERTZBERG SENATOR DODD.
I HAVE A FEW QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
BECAUSE A I'M NEW TO THE
COMMITTEE ND AND LEARNING SO
PREFIGURE PART I WAS JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT --
A COUPLE THINGS THE FIRST WAS A
YOUR YOU'RE YOU'RE SAYING YOU'RE
INDEPENDENT BUT YOU ARE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE CPUC IS THAT
CORRECT.
WE'RE NOT EXACTLY A DEPARTMENT
IT IS AN INTERESTING
RELATIONSHIP --
WE ARE AN INDEPENDENT OFFICE AT
THE PC SO WHERE PHYSICALLY
LOCATED AT THE P. C. AND WE
SHARE CERTAIN RESOURCES WITH
THEM -- BUT
AT THE SAME TIME.
OVER TME THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS CREATED AND STRENGTHEN OUR
INDEPENDENCE SO THAT WE CAN
SPECIFICALLY REPRESENT RATE
PAYERS IN.
C. P. PROCEEDINGS AND AND OTHER
FOR SINGLE MINDED MISSION WHICH
IS WHICH I MENTIONED EARLIER TO
TO ACHIEVE THE LOWEST POSSIBLE
RATES FOR CUSTOMERS CONSISTENT
WITH SAFETY RELIABILITY IN THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS.
WITHOUT ON THE WEEK THAT IS OUR
MISSION AND THAT SEPARATE AND
DISTINCT FROM WHAT WHAT THE PC
DOES [inaudible]
AND THEN.
SINCE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT WILD
FIRES YOU KNOW THERE'S ALWAYS
TRYING TO BE PROACTIVE AND
REACTIVE AND IT SEEMS LIKE WE'RE
MORE IN A REACTIVE.
MODE AND AND I USE THE CITY OF
ANAHEIM IS AN EXAMPLE THEY'VE
SORT OF BEEN PROACTIVE IN
WORKING ON REDUCING THE ABILITY
OF SPARKS TO BECAUSE WILD FIRES
IN THEIR AREAS ARE CANYON TO
CENTER AND SO I'M JUST.
SORT OF CURIOUS --
YOU SAVE THREE BILLION LAST YEAR.
BUT A LITTLE BIT OF A RATE
INCREASE WOULD HAVE SAVED A LOT
MORE AND PROPERTY LOSS I DON'T
KNOW WHAT DOLLAR AMOUNT WE'RE
TALKING WHAT THIRTY TEN TIMES
MORE.
AND AND SO I'M JUST KINDA
CURIOUS WORD WORDS THE BALANCE
OF OF STAVING.
TAX IF YOU KNOW RATE PAYERS
SOMETHING BUT ALSO WORKING ON
THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF GETTING
PROACTIVE.
YES WE WE ARE STRONGLY IN FAVOR
OF BEING PROACTIVE I I THINK
THAT INVESTING IN IMPROVING THAT
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO PREVENT AND MITIGATE FIRES IS
PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WAYS TO SAVE NOT ONLY
LIVES BUT BUT CUSTOMERS.
MONEY IN THE IN THE LONG RUN SO --
SO YEAH I FEEL I FEEL STRONGLY
ON THAT THAT THAT THAT IS A
PRIORITY AND THAT'S CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THE PAST
WE HAVE.
ADVOCATED IN A NUMBER OF
PROCEEDING SAFETY INVESTMENTS
EVEN IF THEY HAVE A PRICE TAG
ATTACHED TO THEM --
SO WHAT WE WHAT WE TRY TO DO WE
WERE ACTUALLY INSTRUMENTAL IN
SETTING UP A PROCESS WHERE THE
THE SAFETY RISKS WERE TAKEN OUT
OF THE GENERAL RATE CASE AND
LOOKED AT UP FRONT.
SO YOU WEREN'T MODELING THE THE
SAFETY ISSUES WITH THE FINANCIAL
ISSUES QUITE AS MUCH SO YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THE SAFETY ISSUES IN
DECIDING.
IN A TRANSPARENT WAY WHAT DOES
NEED TO BE PRIORITIZED IN TERMS
OF OF SAFETY RISKS AND THEN AND
THEN AND THEY GENERATE CASE WE
TALK ABOUT HOW MUCH IT SHOULD
COST.
SO WE WE WOULD NOT OPPOSE --
A SAFETY INVESTMENT THAT WAS WAS
A PRIORITY FOR THE UTILITY --
WHAT WE MIGHT DO IS IS IF THEY
WERE COMING IN AT? THREE TO FIVE
TIMES WHAT WHAT YOU KNOW OTHER
UTILITIES WHERE WE'RE SAYING WE
MIGHT ASK WHY IS THIS GOING TO
COST YOU SO MUCH IN YOUR
TERRITORY VERSUS WHAT IT'S
COSTING AND IN ANOTHER PART OF
THE STATE --
AND YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY COULD
JUSTIFY MAYBE THE TRAIN IS AT
DIFFERENT BUT THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS WE WOULD ASK
NOT YOU SHOULDN'T DO IT THE BUT
IN BUT BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
IS APPROPRIATE MOUNT.
THAT THAT SHOULD COST YEAH AND
I'M FINDING PERHAPS THAT IT COST
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A MILE.
TO UNDERGROUND UTILITY LINES
WHICH IS NOT LOST LIVES AND
PROPERTY SO I'M JUST CURIOUS
MISTER PICKER SAID HEY WE'RE
GONNA KEEP TELEPHONE POLES
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PUT UP FIVE
G..
BUT CAN'T WE UNDERGROUND THE
ELECTRICITY --
TO PREVENT SPARKS IN THE WINDY
CONDITIONS AND THEN HAVE LIGHT
POLES WITH THE FIVE G. EIGHT UP
ON THERE AS AS AS AS AN OPTION.
I'VE GOT A MEETING THAT'S WHAT
I'M THINKING SO MAYBE YEAH
RESPOND TO HIS ANSWER HE YEAH
WELL THEY YEAH IT'S AN
INTERESTING POINT YEAH I THINK
YOU CERTAINLY CAN UNDERGROUND
UNDERGROUND UTILITIES AND THEN
HAVE.
HAVE THAT INFRASTRUCTURE FOUR
FOUR FIVE G. I MEAN CERTAINLY
CURRENTLY WITH WITH FOUR G. YOU
CAN HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
STILL HAVE UTILITIES UNDERGROUND
ANYWHERE WHERE I LIVE I'M
FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO HAVE.
EVERYTHING WAS UNDERGROUND IN
TWENTY YEARS AGO WHERE I LIVE SO --
VERY HAPPY TO HAVE THAT BUT I
STILL FOR THE MOST BURKE ITSELF
CELL COVERAGE SO --
YEAH I THINK I THINK IT IS
POSSIBLE TO DO BOTH IT IS
EXPENSIVE IT'S NOT IT'S NOT
CHEAP.
CENTER DOT IF YOU IF YOU'RE NOT
FINISHED THE IDEA BEHIND FOR
ASIAN.
FIVE IT IS IT IS NOT NOT AN
EXPERT HERE ON ON ON RATES AND
EVERYTHING BUT I'VE LEARNED AN
AWFUL LOT THE LAST SIXTEEN
MONTHS.
THE IDEA THAT WE'RE GONNA GET
RESILIENCY AND HAVE THE
UTILITIES PARTICULARLY PGD.
TRIM ALL THE TREES AT IT NEEDS
TRIMMED IN ORDER TO GET IN
COMPLIANCE TO PROVIDE SAFETY.
THE IDEA THEY'RE GONNA DO THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH ALL THESE
RIDICULOUS.
I MEAN.
THERE IT IT'S IT'S LIKE. EIGHT
TO FIFTEEN TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE
THAN HANGING ALLIANCE.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I'M HEARING IS
IS THESE NEW.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE TOUGH
LONG COATED LINES WITH.
MOVING TOWARDS THAT IN THE
FUTURE IS PROBABLY MORE COST
EFFECTIVE. FOR RATEPAYERS THAN
TO GO THROUGH YOU KNOW ALL THESE
WERE ALL AREAS AND HE POWER
LIGHT AND BE NOT POWER LIGHTS
BUT POLLS.
AND AND THEN ALSO --
YOU KNOW BURY THE ELECTRICAL I'M
I'M I'M JUST SAYING.
I DON'T THINK IT'S REALISTIC I
THINK THAT THE RATE PAYERS THEN.
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
APPROVE IT.
DURING SB NINE OH ONE TURN --
THE REPAIR ADVOCATES FOR AG IN
BUSINESS AND THE MANUFACTURERS.
THEY ALL OPPOSE.
NINE OH ONE WHICH WOULD HAVE
MADE IT BETTER. FOR ALL THEIR
RATE PAYERS.
ARE YOU IN THE LONG RUN TO TAKE
BUT TO TAKE.
YOUR THE COST OVER ABOVE WHAT P.
JEANNIE COULD PAY IN THE IN THAT
PARTICULAR CASE.
AND THEN MOVE IT OFF ON A TWENTY
YEAR BOND LET'S SAY.
IT JUST TO DEAL TO TO ME.
IT JUST SHOWED ME HOW VERY VERY
DIFFICULT IT WOULD BE. TO GET
ANYTHING THROUGH THE RATE CASE--
YOU KNOW DID TO DO THIS --
IF FOR STRUCTURE.
ENHANCEMENT OTHER THAN WHAT WAS.
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY.
I'M NOT GONNA WHAT YOU THINK LIZ
BUT WHAT IT DOES TO BE CLEAR SO
I'M NOT NECESSARILY ADVOCATING
FOR A FOR UNDERGROUND --
EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW I'M JUST%
TRYING TRYING TO BE RESPONSIVE
TO IT TO THE QUESTION --
BUT YEAH YOU KNOW I THINK
CERTAINLY.
WE WANT TO ACHIEVE A SAFE RESULT
IN IN THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE
MANNER [inaudible]
POSSIBLE.
BUT WE GOT TO BE REALISTIC AND
IN TERMS OF WHAT THE RATE BASE.
IS GOING TO WANT TO PAY FOR YES
YES WILL YOU WON'T GET ANY
ARGUMENT FROM US ON THAT WE ARE
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
ABOUT ALL OF THIS PILING ON OF
OF OF RATES ON TO THAT CONSUMER
AT THE STATE YEAH.
THANK YOU.
SO CENTER GOD.
I TOLD RESPECT WHAT YOU'VE JUST
SAID.
I HAVE A CITY IN MY DISTRICT
THAT IS ACTUALLY WANTING TO
UNDERGROUND IT WAS WILLING TO
PAY FOR IT AND IS HAVING SUCH A
DIFFICULT TIME.
WITH THE CPUC AND WITH UTILITIES
AND AND THEY ARE THEY EVEN HAD A
BALLOT MEASURE.
IN NOVEMBER TO INCREASE SALES
TAX JUST UNDERGROUND.
UTILIZED BECAUSE THEY'RE AFRAID
OF THE FIRE NOW THAT WHAT
THEY'VE SEEN WHAT HAPPENED IN
YOUR COMMUNITY.
WHAT HAPPENED TO OTHERS THEY'RE
THEY'RE EVEN MORE --
FOCUSED ON IT SO THAT'S WHY I'M
ASKING SOME OF THOSE QUESTIONS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO PREVENT.
IN INTO TO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
IF YOU'VE GOT A COMMUNITY THAT
WANTS TO INVEST.
IN THEIR COMMUNITY AND PAY FOR
THE UNDERGROUND YOU'RE
SUBSTANTIALLY PAY FOR THE UNDER
GROUNDING.
I MEAN I I CAN'T IMAGINE WHY
THAT WOULD TAKE A LONG.
A LOT OF TIME --
AND CONSERVATION EVERYTHING TO
GET COMPLETED YEAH ACTED
CURTAINS.
WE SHOULD TALK OFF LINE
[inaudible]
SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU MISTER.
CHAIR BY STIRS GLACIER --
SHARE THE SAME.
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SPEEDOF THE
UNDERGROUND IN PROCESS EVEN
THOUGH EVEN FOR THOSE WHO WANT
TO PAY FOR IT OF HEARD SOME
CREATIVE IDEAS --
TO BUT I WANTED TO FOCUS BACK ON
THIS -- TO
RATE PAYER QUESTION I WAS
GETTING AT WITH THE WITH BAKER
AND HIS TEAM IN TERMS OF COSTS
ON THE ELECTRIC SIDE THAT ARE
GETTING SORT OF EMBEDDED FROM --
FROM GAS PIPELINE SAY SAFETY
YOUR REPAIR COSTS.
SO FIRST QUESTION IS REALLY
ABOUT THE REASONABLENESS OF
INCLUDING THAT IN ELECTRIC RATES
SAY IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO
WE'VE HEARD A BILLION DOLLARS
FOR THIS WINTER TO DO SO SUPPLY.
CONSTRAINTS I STILL HAVE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE REPAIR
PROCESS PERIOD --
HAVE YOU GUYS LOOKED AT THAT AT
ALL AND ARE THERE ANY.
IN THE END UNLESS WE'RE ABLE TO
SHOW THAT SAY THE THERE WAS LIKE
A WILLFUL OR NEGLIGENT ACT BY.
THE GAS COMPANY NOT TO REPAIRS A
LINE TO THIRTY FIVE IS THERE%
ANYTHING ANY OTHER WAY TO SORT
OF PREVENT THOSE COSTS FROM
BEING JUST SORT OF INSTANTLY
PASSED THROUGH WITHOUT ANY
OVERSIGHT TO SEVEN CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC RATE PAYERS.
YES SO FIRST OF ALL WE WOULD
CERTAINLY IF IF EITHER AS C. E.
OR SO CAL GAS IS FOUND
RESPONSIVE AND THAN THOSE COSTS
A HUNDRED MILLION OR ONE MILLION
DOLLARS.
IT SHOULD NOT BE PASSED ALONG TO
IT TO RATE PAYERS AND IT DOESN'T
HAVE TO BE WILL FALL CERTAINLY
NEGLIGENCE WILL DO I'VE IF IT'S
SHOWN THAT THEY HAVEN'T.
ACTED IN A RESERVE AS A
REASONABLY PRUDENT MANAGER IS
THE STANDARD --
SO AND THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
FIRST THING AND THEN --
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF THOSE COSTS
GETTING PASSED ALONG IN THE IN
THE SHORT TERM I'M ACTUALLY
GONNA LET LINDA JUMP IN HERE.
ANSWER THAT PART.
ON THE GAS AND ELECTRIC SIDE WE
HAVE ACTUALLY IN OUR PLEADINGS --
HAVE.
A IDENTIFIED THE ISSUE RATE
PAYER RESPONSIBILITY AND SAYING
THAT IF THE UTILITIES ARE
RESPONSIBLE.
OF THROUGH NEGLIGENCE THE
NEGLIGENCE OR IMPRUDENCE OF VENN
CERTAINLY RIGHT HERE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO PAY AND THAT THERE
SHOULD BE SEPARATE WHAT WE CALL
MEMORANDUM ACCOUNTS OR TRACKING
ACCOUNTS. TO BOOK THE LEAST SO
CANYON ANY A LEASE SO CAN YOU
RELATED COSTS SO FOR EXAMPLE I
THINK YOU KNOW THIS THERE BEEN
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAMS.
THAT WERE NISH INITIATED TO TRY
TO ADDRESS A REALLY HATE THE
SITUATION IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
DUE TO THE SHUTDOWN OF OF LISA
CANYON.
AND WE WE ARE PLEADING SO THAT
SHOULD.
OF THE UTILITY BE FOUND AT FAULT
THE WILL KNOW WHAT BECAUSE
SHOULD REVERT BACK TO THE
UTILITY NOT SURE HOLD AND
REPAIRS.
GOTCHA AND DO YOU THINK THAT
THIS.
IS THIS LINE THOUGH RELATED TO A
LEASE SO OR OR NOT LIKING IT FIT
INTO THAT SEPARATE MEMORANDUM
ACCOUNT OR IS THERE SOME OTHER.
THERE HAS TO BE SORT OF
INDEPENDENTLY.
ADOPTED BY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION FOR THIS BECAUSE IT
pHAPPENING INTO WITH LINE I THINK
IT'S LINE.
ONE THOUSAND ANOTHER COMBAT
BECAUSE THE WHEN THEY THEY'RE
REPAIRING TO THIRTY FIVE VERY
EXPEDITIOUSLY NOW IT'S
INTERESTING WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THE PC CALLS AND STARTS ASKING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AFTER A YEAR
OF DOING NOTHING.
BUT BUT YEAH WELL I I JUST WANT
TO SEE IS REPEAT THIS IN THE
NEXT WINTER SEASON IF THEY'RE
OFFLINE AGAIN --
SO IS THERE HOW DID THESE HOW TO
THE THAT MAKE THE DECISION ABOUT
THAT TRACKING OR THAT A THAT.
CASH ACCOUNTING. TO MY IN MY
EXPERIENCE USUALLY A PARTY HAS
TO REQUEST A CONTINENT SOMETHING
THAT IS JUST DONE.
SOMETIMES THE TOADIES WILL
REQUESTED IF IT IF IT'S IN THEIR
FAVOR FRANKLY --
AND SO WILL IT WILL WILL ALWAYS
REQUEST A MEMORANDUM ACCOUNT --
IF WE BELIEVE THAT IT'S GOING TO
PROTECT REPAIRS AND POTENTIALLY
SHIELD THEM FROM THOSE COSTS AT
THE UTILITIES FOUND AT FAULT IS
IS IS THAT SOME OF YOU GUYS ARE
WILLING TO CONSIDER ON TO THIRTY
FIVE YES.
OKAY -- AND
AND THEN JUST THE FINAL QUESTION
THERE WOULD BE CHIU TO JUST IN
GENERAL WITH OUR PIPELINE SYSTEM
I KNOW WE'VE BEEN REALLY FOCUSED
ON WILDFIRES TODAY BUT I'M.
THERE THERE'S A LOT OF WE'RE
SEEING A LOT OF THESE KINDS OF
LINES OF THEY CAN'T SENSE
REMOTELY.
THE RUPTURES ON EVEN DETECTED
IMMEDIATELY.
EVERYONE SCARED ABOUT SAN BRUNO
BUT THERE'S PLENTY OTHERS AND I
WOULD APPLAUD YOU BY THE WAY ON
THE YOU'VE DONE SOME WORK AROUND
COMMUNITIES NEARBY NATURAL GAS
TRANSMISSIONS LINES I BELIEVE.
YEAH WHICH LINE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
THAT WAS VERY IMPORTANT
REASONING BUT JUST.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND YOU ALL
AS THE OFFICE OF THAT THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE
I GOTTA GET USED TO THAT --
ONE DO YOU HAVE SUFFICIENT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TO
EVALUATE THE EFFICACY OF VARIOUS
EXPENDITURES SAY ON REPAIRS.
MAINTENANCE LIKE DEPRECIATION
SCHEDULES TIMING IN DO YOU HAVE
ENOUGH DATA DO YOU THINK TO MAKE.
ASSESSMENTS ON THE PRUDENCE OF
VARIOUS PROPOSED GAS
TRANSMISSION.
UPGRADES.
YEAH OUT WELL WHAT WHAT WE DO IN
ANY GIVEN PROCEEDING IF A
UTILITY COMES IN AND REQUEST AN
UPGRADE --
WE WOULD WE WOULD ASK FOR THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION AND WE WOULD
GET THE DATA THA WE NEED TO TO
EVALUATE THAT WE HAVE FOUND IN A
NUMBER OF INSTANCES THAT.
RECORD KEEPING ISN'T WHAT IT
SHOULD BE --
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THAT WAS THE
CASE IN SAN BRUNO WHAT WERE SEEN
IT ELSEWHERE IN THE STATE AS
WELL AND AND YOU KNOW IF YOU
DON'T HAVE GOOD RECORDS ABOUT
AND THEN EXACTLY WHAT YOU'VE
GOTTEN THE GROUND.
IT'S VERY HARD TO TO HAVE A LOT
OF CONFIDENCE ABOUT THE SAFETY
FRANKLY SO BUT IT' ON A REAL
IT'S REALLY ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS WHAT I'M HERE I SAY LIKE
THEY'LL PROPOSE SOME UPGRADE
THAT'S RIGHT AND AND THEN YOU.
TRY TO SOLICIT INFORMATION BUT
THERE'S NOT REALLY A PROACTIVE
PROCESS SAVE MAPPING THE ENTIRE
NATURAL GAS TRANSMISSION SYSTEM
IN CALIFORNIA IN THE AGE OF IT --
THAT DOESN'T EXIST NOT THAT I
KNOW OF NOT THAT SPECIFIC EFFORT
BUT THROUGH OF VARIOUS
RESEMBLANCE REVIEWS THAT WERE
THE COMMISSION IS CURRENTLY
CONDUCTING.
WE ARE OF THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE IS CERTAINLY BUILDING
QUITE A DATABASE OF INFORMATION.
OR LACK OF INFORMATION FRANKLY
OF FOM THE UTILITIES SO WE ARE
ACTIVELY GOING AFTER THAT
INFORMATION.
IF YOU IF THERE'S ANY WAY TO A
MASS THAT AND PUT SOME KIND OF
COMPENDIUM TOGETHER I KNOW MY
OFFICE WOULD BE VERY INTERESTED
IN SEEING THAT TO THE EXTENT
IT'S IT'S SHAREABLE WOULD WANT
ANY NON PUBLIC INFORMATION BUT
THINGS HAVING WE'RE KEENLY
INTERESTED IN AND WHICH ONE
FULLY.
ARMED FULLY INFORMED.
YOU KNOW PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSIONERS TO MAKE SOME
DECISIONS HERE BECAUSE THE FACT
IS WHEN YOU BUILD A NEW LINE
THOSE THINGS GET ADVERTISE FOR
NEW HOMEOWNERS I MEAN EVERYONE
BUILDING A NEW HOME NOW.
IN IN CALIFORNIA WHICH WE HOPE
THERE ARE MANY MORE ALL HAVE TO
BEAR THE COST.
OF WHATEVER THAT NATURAL GAS
TRANSMISSION LINE IS OUT THERE
AND ADVERTISE THAT OVER THERE
THEIR RATES NOT THE DEVELOPERS
BUT OVER THERE'S FOR DECADES SO.
IF WE'RE TRYING TO PUSH FOR SB
ONE HUNDRED IS IT REALLY PRUDENT
TO GO BUILD IN A BUNCH NEW MORE
STRANDED SSETS.
WE WE SENATOR WE COULD NOT AGREE
WITH YOU MORE AND WHENEVER THESE
TYPES OF PROPOSALS COME IN THAT
IS EXACTLY HOW WE THINK ABOUT IT
WE SAY IS IS IS IS A
TRANSMISSION LINE.
REALLY NEEDED IN A WATER THE
OTHER WHAT'S AVAILABLE IN TERMS
OF RENEWABLE RESOURCES NEARBY --
BECAUSE WE FULLY AGREE FOR A LOT
OF REASONS IN ADDITION TO COST
YOU WE AND WE DON'T WANT TO
BUILD MORE TRANSMISSION LINES
OUT THERE AND CONFERENCE THAT
ARE NECESSARY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER STERN THANK YOU
MISS ACKLES THANKS FOR GIVING
YOUR ANNUAL REPORT.
I'M SURE --
THIS YEAR IS DIFFERENT --
BUT WE HAVE SOME LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES AND AND THIS IS
AFFECTING ALL OF US.
A INTO OVER ALL BEGINNING
EDUCATED CENTER DOT MENTIONED
HOW MUCH SHE LEARNS IN THE LAST
SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN MONTHS BUT EVEN
FOR ME JUST TO WATCH ONE CITY IN
MY DISTRICT THAT.
WAITED TEN YEARS FOR FIRE MAPS.
YOU KNOW IT'S LIKE REALLY YOU
KNOW IS THIS IS THIS CPUC IS IT
IS IT THAT BIG THAT SLOW THAT
POLITICAL WHAT.
WHAT CAN WE DO IS NOW YOU'RE
UNDER THE MICROSCOPE?
FOR YOU KNOW BOTH OF YOU.
AND IT'S GOING TO BE A REAL LIKE
I SAID A REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOR LEADERSHIP WE GOT A WE CAN
WE CAN DO BETTER.
SO THANK YOU.
FOR COMING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR NOW WILL HAVE TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT.
AND I SEE ONLY ONE PERSON LINED
UP SO YOU HAVE --
EVERY THIRTY MINUTES WELL IF YOU
CAN SENATOR BRADFORD FOR MY
ATTENDANCE --
BOND GILBERT REPRESENTING CLEAN
POWER AT STAFF SAN FRANCISCO'S
COMMUNITY TWICE AGGREGATOR --
I WAS HERE WATCHING OST THE
HEARING WENT BACK TO MY OFFICE
TURNED ON THE TV.
AT THE COME BACK --
SO -- I HAVE
A LOT OF RESPECT AND AFFECTION
FOR SENATOR BRADFORD BY HALF THE
RESPECTFULLY TAKE ISSUE.
WITH HIS COMPARISON OF CCA'S TO
ENRON AND REFERRING TO CCA'S AS
NOTHING BUT THIRD PARTY
REMARKETERS OF ENERGY --
CERTAINLY.
ALL THE OF THE THE I. O. U.'S
CCA'S.
THEY HAVE THEIR ATTRIBUTES AND
THEY HAVE THEIR CHALLENGES
NEITHER SYSTEM IS PERFECT GRANT
YOU THAT --
HOPEFULLY --
YOU ALL WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE
BOTH SYSTEMS BETTER BEFORE THE
YEAR AND BUT I I YOU KNOW I WAS
HERE DURING THE ENERGY CRISIS
WERE LET LOOSE.
REPRESENTING ENERGY CLIENTS.
AND RHYME.
WAS A IS A PRIVATE CORPORATION
THAT WAS PROVEN TO HAVE
PERPETRATED FRAUD.
UPON ITS SHAREHOLDERS UPON P.
JEANNIE AND CALIFORNIA RATE
PAYERS --
YOU KNOW THEY COOK THEIR BOOKS --
THE CCA'S ARE REPRESENTED.
BY LOCAL ELECTIVES ARE LOCAL
ELECTED CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS --
SUPERVISOR AS BOARDS OF
SUPERVISORS OR APPOINTED BY
LOCAL ELECTED'S.
C. C. A.'S ARE THE MOST RECENT
ARE ONE OF THE MOST RESPONSIVE.
FORMS OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
TERMS OF ENERGY DELIVERY THAT
THERE IS --
I WOULD WAGER TO SAY THAT 95% OF
CALIFORNIANS HAVE NO IDEA WHO
THE CALIFORNIA.
WITH THE CPUC AS IF THEY HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THEIR RATES FOR
WITH SOME DECISION THAT AT THAT
ARE REGULATED I OWE YOU.
HAS MADE WITH REGARD TO ENERGY
ACQUISITION OR SOMETHING ELSE.
IF THEY KNOW THAT THE CPC IS A
REGULATORY BODY.
THERE'S NOT GONNA BE A REAL
VIABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR JOE SMITH
FROM LANCASTER THE COME UP AND
PETITION THE CPUC.
THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE A REAL
VIABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
COME UP AND GO TO ADDIS IN AND
TALK TO THE YOU KNOW SOME SOME
OFFICER OF THAT I OWE YOU.
AND GET REDRESS HOWEVER.
CITIZENS IN THOUGH WHO THEIR
SUPERVISORS ARE THEY KNOW WHO
THEIR CITY COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE
AND THEY AND THEY CERTAINLY KNOW
AND SAN FRANCISCO HOW TO GET
THEIR ATTENTION.
AND IF THEY HAVE A CONCERN ABOUT
THEIR RATES OR ABOUT SOME
DECISION THAT CLEAN POWER SF
MAKES THAT THEY DON'T LIKE.
BELIEVE ME THEY HAVE NO TROUBLE.
THE SEEKING REDRESS SO I WOULD
HAVE AND I HAVE TO SAY THAT TO
COMPARE LOCAL ELECTED'S. TO TO
THE CORPORATE BOARD OF A BOARD
THAT COMMITTED FRAUD ON THIS
STATE IN FACT THERE FOR WHICH
MANY WERE ALL STILL PAYING THREE
D. W. R. BILL. THIRTY W. OUR
CONTRACTS IS REALLY --
I THINK A BIT ON THE RECKLESS
SIDE -- SO I
JUST I I ALSO WANT TO SAY ONE
OTHER THING THEN I'LL I'LL GET
OUT OF YOUR HAIR --
I UNDERSTAND I WASN'T HERE FOR
IT SO I APOLOGIZE IF I'M
MISTAKEN.
THAT THERE WAS A
CHARACTERIZATION MADE THAT CCA'S
ONLY PAY ATTENTION TO CLEAN
ENERGY FIRST OF ALL WE GLADLY
ACCEPT THAT MANTLE IF IF THAT
WAS STATED.
AND PROUDLY --
SINCE SINCE WE NEED TO DE
CARBONIZED --
TO TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
HORRIBLE WEATHER EVENTS THAT
CAUSE.
THE BUSINESS THE SUPER FIRES
WERE DEALING WITH DON'T AND
OCCUR.
BUT I ALSO JUST WANT TO SAY FY I
THAT CCA'S DO A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS TWO QUICK EXAMPLES AND
I'M DONE WITH MY TESTIMONY.
CINEMAS CCA HASN'T HAS ENABLED
MANY WHO WOULD NOT OTHERWISE BE
BE ABLE TO PURCHASE.
ELECTRIC VEHICLES TO DO SO
LANCASTER CCA HAS ENABLED THE
CITY TO ACQUIRE GHG FREE PUBLIC
BUSES.
SO WE DO A LOT OF STUFF SO THANK
YOU FOR THE OP MISTER GILBERT I
SAID THIRTY MINUTES I WAS
KIDDING.
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS US IN PUBLIC COMMENT --
WELL THEN WE ARE OFFICIALLY
ADJOURNED AS OUR UNLESS THERE'S
ANYTHING OF TWENTY OKAY THANK
YOU